[Music]
welcome everybody
h3tv is monday it's that sigma alpha
grind set
we are here on time
two grind
i just downed
a boiled chicken breast and a handful of
spinach you know what's up
wow
what's that sigma grindset oh yeah
let's get that let's get this let's get
that
it's too early to start dropping s-bombs
today enjoy it live
thank you bill
uh today's episode is sponsored by
curology hello fresh me undies and quip
we love them folks don't we
new episode of leftovers is out comes
out on sunday it came out on sunday it's
there if you want to watch
a little bit of a show update for you
guys it's mine and ela's anniversary
which one is this nine
years
almost this is almost a big one
yeah ten we gotta do something man yeah
nine years we got married in october
twenty
20
12 10 10 12. if i did that nine years
ago
[Music]
that's kind of a long time
i'd say so
you know kind of
that's pretty cool
you know he's sick yeah you guys bullied
us by the way speaking of which to
consider changing our our uh future
son's name so
i hope you all are proud of yourself
no not you
the subreddit and everyone there was
like all these super mean memes about
bruce's name
which
i don't know apparently my all my family
and everyone hated the name too
well so
because
you jokingly said it was inspired by
batman yeah and it was like no no it's
not is there like a family like is there
a origin story to it no there's no story
we just like the name oh okay fair
enough we liked the name
and then everyone's like
i don't know what why do people there's
lots of cool bruces bruce is the fine
man i thought every bruce i know is cool
and i've never met bruce springsteen
he's the boss
wayne okay that's a fictional character
bruce almighty
bruce willis
uh bruce willis yeah why you hate bruce
willis
he has a reputation for being kind of a
jerk you hate other bald men dan it's
not about that it's not about that
also it's like that
but i mean he's he's great and
a slew of movies so good well anyway
thank good job guys you guys bullied us
into changing this our kids name so
success
but we have some good alternatives now
but i'm not going to say them because
you guys are going to ruin
you're going to get me in the doghouse
again
seeing bruce is awesome bruce is cool
though
i like bruce bruce campbell that's right
the king of
b movies
bruce lee
brook bruce lee what's wrong what's a
cool bro that's what i'm saying wait
hassan did hassan just oh
cam's writing under hassan that's so
confusing boys using the laptop that
uses i was like wait are songs watching
sean pecker
um
anyway
brucie from matilda okay oh i didn't
announce so anyway it's our ninth
wedding anniversary me and ela are
taking a little trip this weekend
so
we are gonna be
thank you zach
so we are going to be uh making some
show changes this friday after dark is
going to start at 11
instead of 12 30
and
um on monday we're moving h3 tv
to tuesday
to give us a little bit of a long
weekend there
so thank you thank you and we'll
continue to announce that
as we get closer guys if you want to
call and share story
or anything you know the number 808 hot
meme
let's get this [ __ ] let's get this [ __ ]
let's get this [ __ ]
screeners are standing by to take your
calls
uh gabe uh gabe is out here on monday
posting some interesting content white
claw gabe
selfie with the toilet and just blasted
out of his mind you could tell from his
eyes
this [ __ ] picture
dude what
why is he taking out selfie with the
toilet did he mean to i mean it looks so
intentional
monday's for the toilet what does he
mean what does it mean
what does it mean
after a long
drinking weekend
covering from friday like he puked dirty
[ __ ] a little bit of both
dude gabe party's so hard man
love that
it's kind of got the same grin as the
the the arson girl meme oh interesting
yeah he just he just burned down the
toilet
so similar crime
yeah [ __ ] one of my favorite nights
oh yeah
got some great keemstar memes at the top
of the show
hold on on the typewriter zack we'll get
to that
you don't even know what we're gonna say
yet maybe it's nice
by the way can you turn the acm i'm a
little cold up in this eh oh turn it
down yeah turn it down a little bit yeah
thank you so much
it's like a draft
so
i'm so sad to say this because
unlike trisha i don't monitors people's
channels
i don't
pray for people's downfalls or their
views to drop
or anything like that
i firmly believe that there's room
enough in the world for all of us you
know what i mean
but i'm just showing this in context of
of keemstar's
tweets of course
is that his views seem to have like
considerably
fallen off
and i'm i'm wondering
like he he up until a month ago would
hit like what a million per video every
time easy right like if you go back
two months ago million million million
million million
every time
but now all of a sudden
in the past i'd say three weeks
i mean who wouldn't want to click this
right
i'm not [ __ ] i'm not fat funny i mean
that's a banger
that's [ __ ] up
right i mean
well anyway what is this a male game
it's so
hey come on these these are top notch
this is the top drama channel on all of
youtube
funny i mean his graphics are top notch
look at that keem
wait what the [ __ ] what is this story
are you high bro
okay well hold on keemstar let me get to
it there is a story here
well anyway his views have dropped off
considerably
i mean he posted one a week ago that
only he's three and sixty thousand which
you know is a lot but for him
and now first of all my i was trying to
wonder why this has happened to him and
i i honestly think
that it's a combination
it's not it's ironically it's nothing
nobody said about him it's what he's
done to himself
right i thought as well 100
you know
like
nothing anybody ever said about keemstar
being the worst person all the stuff
he's done just being irredeemable human
being
had a real effect on his viewership
but the man responsible for this i'm not
responsible for this
i didn't do anything
i think it's a it's a combination of the
aidan ross
debacle
the aiden the ayden roche stream cringe
i mean that that was like cringe comp
yeah eternity yeah
and what was specifically bad about that
for keemstar and maybe we should revisit
it just because why not
just for the sake of journalistic
yeah some people may have some viewers
may not have seen it it's true
but what's interesting about that is
that it struck right at the heart of his
viewers which is like young men
young boys or whatever probably
i think the overlap of aiden ross fans
and keemstar fans is like 90
and so
showing up on aiden's stream and and
posting cringe like that
struck at the heart of his fans
and they realized like damn this is just
some
cringey-ass boomer who like is not cool
actually
and then that in combination with the
openly courting 18 year old girls on
twitter
has created a ripple effect of
people finally realizing i think just
you know
sheer through
evidence i mean it's undeniable what a
cringy
uh
he's just
an embarrassing human being i mean he's
he's older than me he's 40 almost 40.
and he's trying to act like he's 18. and
the whole thing is just a disaster it's
like a romeo julia but here it is for
those of you don't remember because i
mean it is
it is truly
[Applause]
one of the great moments in history
and as much as i
as much as i like to talk about aiden
ross and i've had an issue with him
what is up dramaalert what is this 30
seconds i don't know why i didn't send
the timestamp
oh okay so 30 seconds yeah yeah as much
as i've had a thing with aiden ross i
have to thank him for creating this
situation because adam ross exposed
keemstar more than i or anyone else
could ever have right
on uh we facetime facetime yeah
now he's [ __ ] famous somehow and i'm
thinking oh you're in trouble why oh
[ __ ] that crypto [ __ ]
crickets bro oh i see i didn't have to
say cricket clarity
right now
what's up buddy how you doing
[Music]
yo this is an awesome video
real good
[Music]
i think you should box here's why you
have natural energy they see it in the
stream right you need that
like you have natural energy like ksi
oh by the way the other great thing
about this is worth mentioning because
it's like such old news now this is his
how old was his girlfriend at the time
20 yeah so he has his 20 year old
girlfriend that he's been like
plastering everywhere and like bragging
about just standing quietly behind him
like it's like
the taliban or some [ __ ]
like stand behind me don't talk
so
there's that thank you ian this is great
i'll show this afterwards but when he
was
what
bro what are you talking about man ethan
caught some strikes from my new
relationship my girl right here do you
want to introduce your girlfriend this
is my girlfriend josie
nice to meet you you can say hi right
here
[Laughter]
i never called him a a p word
well i may have thoughts
i may have said he's epstein without a
billion dollars but
we just weird
yeah yeah but i know what you're saying
i'm 39 she's 20 so he came in
or whatever and he was like saying that
this is the best video on the internet
mega i haven't seen this is the best
thing ever shout out to five packs in
fact let's link this in the description
yeah of course i want to create this
excellent artist
i mean when we're done we can go back i
just want to credit this guy i mean this
is a fantastic way i can add it right
now
let's wait till the end
let's not mess around with the live
but for the vaude
[Music]
i had like a little dick my dick didn't
work as [ __ ] and he got broke
on the fence what do you think about
that
he legitimately went on his show this
[ __ ] wanted to show he said it
was on anti-depressants
side effects were that he didn't have
feeling in his dick yeah
projection he was trying to put that on
me
thank god his kids just
this is too much dude the silence in the
room the one guy can't take cl he just
he just gets up and walks out
it's just this is the worst vibe ever
there's when we reacted to this on the
show i think we just clipped a few parts
so there's parts of this i haven't seen
before and this is even worse than i
thought it's just this is brutal also
like dude you're there to like
chill with the homies and why are you
even talking about me like it's so sad
nobody
nobody in that room probably knows who
you are except aidan because we talk and
also aiden doesn't care like also it's
not not it's like this fool is depres it
takes antidepressants first of all loser
and its side effects makes uh and it has
side effects on him
love damn you're trying to do it aidan
dude he just failed
yo that dude just
bailed in the middle of keemstar's
anecdote because it was so uncomfortable
the lie detector the hood [ __ ] lie
detected the test
[Music]
the lie detector the hood
dude chill bro you didn't even hear what
he said
this he's he is
i don't i can't take anymore this is a
vibe killer i think he's
responsible solely for his drop in views
this video and everything terrible
keemstar has done as a person and and in
his career
nothing beats posting cringe
yeah because he's always alone in his
basement so now we get to see him around
other people and see his kids see that
he's not cool
i just peed in my basement
[Laughter]
i'm like quartering it's definitely cool
aiden is so upset he invited cam i mean
he's killing the whole vibe
absolutely not
bro
all right
bro
absolutely no
it was look at him
yeah
oh it's done
we're out there
all things solved
[Applause]
uh which video was it's uh this one i
was so excited to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] i
couldn't wait to be a [ __ ] horror i
was so excited
anyway
so just a reminder also just a reminder
keem's worst nightmare
is coming to fruition here
if you compare his social blades three
million views in the past 30 days
um
death noodles who we know keemstar has
been deathly afraid of he has 5 million
death noodles
is taking over keemstar's spot
subscribe to deaf noodles you know
anyway
we're leading to a point here
uh is
that keemstar thinks youtube is broken
so
someone's typing into the microphone i
apologize i just want to point i'm sorry
this keyboard is really loud but the sub
difference between keem and def is crazy
as well def has less than a million
while keem has almost 6 million
well anyway here's keemstar's
explanation uh for why his views are
down and you know
this is of this is not surprising at all
that this is his theory ah
i've been tracking how fast a video gets
views
on youtube for dramaalert since like
2017
and it would take anywhere between 15
minutes and 30 minutes to get the first
hundred thousand views like that's just
standard
forever since the beginning of time like
you know so many people have the
notifications on for drama so when the
notifications go out like bam that first
100k comes in real fast right but
because it's news like
like the video always dies off right
like it does it's not like a normal
video where you could watch it like two
weeks and still be entertained by it
because it's like time sensitive right
so
the view is always coming super fast on
dramar
uh
it took like two hours to get 100k views
yesterday
and the video is sitting at 300 000
views it's been like 20 hours the
snapchat video which is the same exact
content is that 2 million views
what's going on
what's going on
i know i'm on twitter so the response is
you fell off you fell off you fell i get
it i get it i gotta get it but
something's wrong
yeah i think they're right
i actually think twitter got it right
this time
i love something's wrong with the
delivery system something's wrong with
the notification yeah there's something
wrong with the delivery system keemstar
there's something very wrong with the
delivery system
system
there's somehow my fans are not being
notified when i upload and i know that
because
this
drama it's like a fine oil machine like
as soon as the video is out like you
guys rush to it you watch it and then
the video like slowly slowly slowly dies
off right like it's just i know how this
works it always happens all right
that rush is gone when i upload a video
it's like
you guys don't know that i just uploaded
a video you know you're not getting
something
somewhere like something is [ __ ]
something at youtube the [ __ ] is [ __ ]
broken and it's so [ __ ] frustrating a
month ago
i know zach come on where is this so
frustrating
infuse the video and then all of a
sudden 600k what what happened
700k what happened
and then it just every video that i
upload is like [ __ ] 10 out of 10. and
it's it's gets worse and worse and worse
what is happening
yeah so i think what's happening is that
well what happens is when people stop
engaging with your content youtube stop
showing it to them
right because people are subscribed to
like hundreds of channels and youtube is
smart they say you're not engaging with
this content you never click the videos
you haven't clicked the video in two
months we're going to stop sending you
the video
that sounds and it codes it's crazy
because it coincides so much directly
like can you tell me the date of when
that aiden ross stream happened
because like you can draw a correct a
direct correlation i it is really
amazing
yeah because up until about it was late
august i know that so this is so
interesting because here
around this time he was getting a
million per
like let me click this one
so this is the first one you notice a
small decline this is august 26th
august 26th you notice a small decline
yeah def noodles video about it is on
august 25th no way
so look at this so this was posted the
day after okay
a small decline
and ever since
you know with a few exceptions here and
there like this jake paul one
um the views have gotten lower and lower
and lower
dude it's aiden ross posted cringe dude
i mean like you said that's the number
one sin on the internet
yeah aiden ross the king maker and the
king destroyer as well
so shout out to aiden ross for doing
what none of us ever could
which is destroy keemstar
uh wow fellas keemstar
should we mark that date on the calendar
august august 26th the day the cringe
was posted
the cringe heard round the world
yeah another hot keemstar take while
we're on the topic um
just watched this 2005 movie oh my god
you kids have no idea back in the day
they used to make movies called cook
they used to make movies called comedies
they were hilarious sadly they don't
make them anymore because of social
justifiers and cancel culture
ironically i don't know how many people
have seen waiting i've seen it a couple
times
wait is that andy milinakis i don't
remember him being in the movie yeah
he's not
oh
yeah ironically the the main character
that ryan reynolds plays
was uh
being courted by
young girls is that right his one of the
main plot threads in the movie is about
ryan reynolds character
trying to [ __ ] the hostess at the
restaurant who's like 16 or something
yeah sound familiar yeah
he's like wonder what it was about this
movie that uh keemstar [ __ ] king pound
he's so appealing yeah i was like i
really identify with the plot of this
too bad
hey fred i mean i got a 30 rotten
tomatoes
really i i i remember enjoying it but
man it's been a while i thought when it
came out it was marginally funny and i
haven't thought about it ever since
basically a good flick if you're a
waiter i feel like
yeah there was more that was
66.7
um
yeah it wasn't very hot at the time
everyone's like this movie sucks
in case i was like you remember good
comedy
it's just like that's just the most
boomer energy ever like they don't make
movies they don't make funny movies
i don't make funny movies classic right
there bar
have you ever meanwhile meanwhile ryan
reynolds is probably trying to get that
movie erased from that yeah exactly the
annals of history
uh anyway fun little uh
i thought it was a fascinating glimpse
into
youtube and what is this [ __ ] guys can
we just take a moment there's another
one
on myself always i always have a moment
for that yeah kim should take his own
advice if he's so worried about youtube
uh here is keemstar's message
to
people looking to pay the rent hey guys
recently i've been doing a lot of
giveaways wait is that is that us oh you
played that zach oh good
and when you do a lot of giveaways you
get people out of the woodworks that are
struggling
that are asking for me to pay their rent
or asking for me to buy my car some some
crazy stuff
and um
you know i there's jobs everywhere guys
right now there's jobs everywhere
any any fast food restaurant has a help
area any department store any restaurant
point blank period there are jobs
everywhere places around me are closing
early because they can't get enough
workers
factories are hiring there's jobs
literally everywhere and i know
every time i've talked about this on
twitter the response is well
those jobs don't give you enough for a
living wage
but sitting on twitter begging a
youtuber to pay your rent is yes that's
the living wage yes i'm sure
i'm sure that's
a real strategy people are uh expecting
of you keemstar
you got to figure it out all right
first of all
get one of those shitty jobs all right
so you have some money coming in
and then when you're not working you got
to do your side hustle which is flipping
stuff on ebay buying stuff at a garage
sale and flipping it on ebay or
whatever uh you know
selling it on amazon what is that dan
you don't want to go there no
right
are you implying keemstar doesn't pay
his taxes i don't know how would i know
that right okay fair enough what there's
so many different side hustles that you
could be doing
all right
so you can like survive and make it but
look if you're gonna sit there and cry
and be like these jobs don't don't pay
enough to
you know survive on um okay well sitting
on the couches
sitting on the [ __ ] couches
like there's no need for all this the
dude is just goofing and like you're
losing your mind doing some kind of
this is like the ultimate conservative
talking point about
people don't want to work making
five dollars an hour
there's a job shortage damn it
joe biden is just paying people to stay
at home
that's your option
complaining complaining is going to fix
it no you have to [ __ ] work yeah shut
up you have to have a side hustle
so um
i don't know what to tell you
but um
games start talking to games no one's
gonna help you shut up
[Laughter]
keemstar for president 2021
anyway that so concludes
our uh analysis uh reporting
on keemstar fantastic
what is this you just sent me
love no love he sent me a super chat i'm
a welder artist and fupa trooper and i
would like to build dan his omega desk i
can customize the desk to dan's heart's
content
how can i get in contact yeah i know
where were you like a week ago yeah we
bought the scorpion i've been debating
this for like a year
you could really build like what could
you like build something
uh we already built the scorpion
yeah we appreciate the offer yeah mr
dead memes but um you blew it viv people
are saying to talk about facebook being
down
yeah i mean that's really interesting we
use whatsapp for the show a lot
and it to me is just like the zuck how
are you [ __ ] up so bad
instagram facebook whatsapp it's all
down and also um apparently they're what
their domain facebook.com is for sale
you can just buy that now
well obviously it wouldn't really work
but
yeah it showed up on a dns website you
have that photo it's pretty funny
yeah does anyone have any details about
what exactly is going down with facebook
because hey this seems to have been it's
i included a little write up right now
it's kind of interesting that this is
happening after the whistleblower leaked
private internal research about the uh
damages oh yeah that was a big story in
60 minutes right yeah 60 minutes
guys facebook.com is for sale
i'm the meat chef that's a huge
opportunity
[Laughter]
yeah um
you know they've had occasional outages
but but it's been going on for a long
time too across all of their services
and uh
i haven't checked in the last 30 minutes
or so but right before the show i was
trying to see
what they were saying about it and
there's
they've only given like vague statements
so far so so it's been down for quite a
while yeah and then we should talk about
what basically there was a big story in
60 minutes where one of their a
whistleblower from inside their company
right said that they have information
that says that
if they
um
oh they're still oh good dude i want
facebook to i want facebook to oh people
already buying it up [ __ ] hogs
god
basically the research was they revealed
that company executives understood the
negative impacts of instagram
on younger users yeah they they
understood that it was causing people to
have increased suicide rates uh
eating disorders depression but fixing
it would mean that they would lose
revenue and so they decided well you
know
we're not going to fix it right i guess
i did something to piss off the
instagram gun
but that's interesting so people are
selling out of a
a moral cell
that doesn't make sense on facebook well
no it's just bad publicity for sure and
then combine that with the fact that all
of their services are crashed this
morning
and the grand scheme of things it's
probably not you know it'll bounce back
yeah it's not by the dip
by the dip hogs
it's the it marks the worst outage for
technology since 2018 so and i mean we
don't even know how much longer it's
going to be going it's still down right
yeah i just tried just now it's just
complete
like nothing when you try and go to
facebook.com man i really
is there any theories floating around as
to nothing
i mean it's it's obviously an attack
right of some sort i saw um
i saw a report that facebook employees
couldn't even get in the building with
their access cards to try and fix it so
wow wait really yeah
weird what the [ __ ] i also saw reports
that twitter amazon and other websites
had issues similar issues so my
twitter's been working all day for me
i'm just saying i'm just seeing all
facebook like it says facebook instagram
messenger and even oculus vrs down
gmail
is trending on twitter right now maybe
they're starting to have problems
yeah we talked before the show that you
should probably reset your
password whatever you can just in case
that's right my gmail works fine
somebody uh used their resubscription on
the membership to say we need to bring
myspace back tom would have fixed it
already yeah so i fixed it you're so
right
tom definitely would have chosen uh
the mental health of young
teenagers over profit
we love tom for that we were just
talking about myspace last night
and just how um
honestly we [ __ ] up by letting myspace
die it it really was the superior you
could you could customize you could play
[ __ ] music how sick was that you
could play your
yeah right every every myspace page
these days would get dmcad yeah i guess
that's true that's true uh but
anyway we have any interesting calls let
me see let me browse
her boyfriend of two years cannot stand
ethan and he wants to figure out a way
to get her boyfriend to see the light
because she wants to enjoy it together
all right
interesting let's do this one and then
we got to do um some ads okay fioroza
uh furiosa
you know that matt maxx
furiosa okay hey
am i saying your name right
oh okay rosa
yeah
um first of all nice to uh talk to you
i'm sorry to hear that your boyfriend
doesn't like me does he by chance watch
keemstar or quartering or temple or
anything like that
oh my god absolutely not
that's good but so i've been watching
you guys like since you lived in israel
um
yeah
and thank you thank you yeah of course
um no he's definitely not like
you know
cringy in that type of way he's just
like too cool for school kind of a
hipster
we live in brooklyn you can you know
sort of paint a picture but um
he just like you know he makes this joke
that like you're the third member of our
household because your shit's always
playing on tv but like he cannot stand
it
and i feel like i've tried um
you know showing him the greatest tips
but it's not really working what should
i do yeah is he we'll leave him
obviously no i'm kidding
what is what's his sense of humor like
what's his favorite who's his favorite
comedy youtuber or yeah a youtuber or a
comedy show or something like that
oh god um
is he funny does he
he doesn't care about comedy
like youtube like i think the commentary
genre just like goes over his head he's
like not big on drama or whatever
um
like we laugh at stuff together you know
we love unusual means that sort of stuff
like you know pretty normal like pretty
low humor i just hit me yeah
yeah by the intellectual kind of comedy
you get on the agency then unusual memes
but okay i'll take it
okay um
what do we do what do we do
is it possible he's jealous of how much
you watch me
you know because he just thinking
because he says oh he's the third member
of our household that seems like kind of
a a comment with a little bit underneath
it right like
he's sick of seeing another man in the
house
you know i i'd say it's your hairline
but he's actually pretty good on that
front so i can't really imagine okay
so it's not the hairline
is he anti-semitic
jewish people
well i am jewish so that would be a deal
forever
just covering our bases here you don't
understand
yeah yeah no he's he's definitely like
right in the head um i i don't know i
think maybe he maybe he's just a little
bit
i think based on that comment about me
being the third person in the house it
seems that he could just be a little bit
jealous of the amount of i'm serious of
not not like that you want me but just
like that you're giving this other dude
so much attention i don't know
could it be that do you think
um
you know i'm not sure he he's like has a
big problem with jealousy but what would
you think is like a good primer you know
to get him
to get him into the hp crew with the
podcast have you showed him my old
videos like the h3h3 production ones
like vape nation and stuff
yeah he's he's seen vape nation he he is
unamused bro there's no i don't know
what to tell you there's no help for
someone
you have to be there though i feel like
you have to be there
get the [ __ ] out
for some people there's just no fix i
don't know what to say i mean i'm not
for everybody i acknowledge that
if if he's a hipster from from
williamsburg or brooklyn or whatever i
mean have you have you checked out
leftovers
that sounds like that might be more up
his alley true political stuff can i ask
a question
have you called in before by chance
oh my gosh no i've tried i tried last
week for the first time this is like my
first time attempting to interact i
generally don't sort of do that wait
hold on hold on what are you getting at
me do you think this is the notorious
well the chat was saying it but i
thought they were being paranoid but i
just listened to the last episode and
they do sound familiar
you you went back and checked the voice
against hers yeah can uh hold on i stand
the line uh for rosa
throw it up throw it up
throw give me a link i'm gonna hear it
and then i want you to talk next to it
and we're gonna get to the bottom of
this
um it's not it's rolling hold on let's
just do it compare okay because we we're
trying to catch this girl
um
so get forgive me for doing this but i'm
gonna play her call real fast hold on
one sec
and there was a group of white ladies
that were all friends as you said
thank you so much i was definitely
worried um yeah you might mistake me for
that that caller not you you're always
forgiven well i don't know what to say i
mean
i'm not uh
i don't
yeah go ahead
is your boyfriend there by chance can i
talk to him
no unfortunately he's at work um i work
from home so the podcast is like a
really great um thing to have on the
background it really supports me so
thank you guys
well thank you so much i'm sorry i don't
have more help on this issue it just
seems like you know he doesn't like
being different and that's fine you know
yeah that's fine it happens and uh
i don't know i hope it doesn't cause you
to stop watching though because that
would not make me happy absolutely not
yeah because your
your loyalty to me comes first
yeah i'm a writer guys
hell yeah god bless you god bless you
all right well
yeah i think maybe try leftovers that
could be up his alley if he's if he's a
lefty
sounds good all right love you guys so
good love you too thank you not that
much not in that way though just
just say your boy just keep it cool with
your boyfriend yeah platonic all right
thank you
appreciate you bye
yeah i mean obviously leave him is the
advice what's wrong with alfredo i mean
she knows that but i mean alfredo is um
see-through with his
of his green uh oh he's green
yeah alfredo's acting are you okay
sweetie he's usually not so like needy
but he keeps jumping up at me i know it
was you afraid of
his eye is like super runny today uh oh
he's seen can someone get me a a kleenex
you've seen what
he just seemed really cheerful a moment
ago like when he saw me he got all
excited like he does yeah but like so i
get worried when he gets like really
needy when he's like jumping at me and
getting on the table because
i'm curiou because he's just more of a
shredder move he's not usually like that
and i wonder if he's trying to tell me
something if he's not feeling well or
something somebody trapped in the well
shred
shred you want to come on shred trapped
in the well oh he's right there okay
good right now
um thank you a.b
a little wet
one here let me let me get a wipe here
so
hang on let me get a little wipe here
okay you're okay
let's clean your eyes a little bit
somebody um donated 100
us dollars
amanda and said recently moved to a town
with population of 106.
the people my age didn't know what teddy
fresh was now i've shown them the light
and these small town folks are
supporting teddy fresh peace and love
thank you a small town of all teddy
fresh squares
six teddy fresh wearers and a small
thank you thank you well done amanda
thank you amanda that's a very generous
dono
hey um god sorry guys i'm just cleaning
up alfredo's eyes
there's another there was a 50 one on
the topic of gross bathroom cleanup at
work oh we were talking about that last
friday uh worked overnight at kinko's
years ago in seattle and blood would
show up on the ceiling mysteriously what
the [ __ ] eventually realized was from
people shooting up and spraying the
ceiling noped out of that one
how could you spray blood that high
bidet
i mean if it's in the toilet and you
turn on the bidet
what
no
it can forget
they're saying it was from shooting up
oh from shooting up oh yeah i thought i
meant like shooting up the but i've seen
that too
yeah that's how the [ __ ] on the ceiling
okay that i i follow it let's do the ads
and then uh
yeah uh oh this is my bro okay so this
guy in another call lined up
sean students
who [ __ ] himself at school wait one of
sean's students my brother
oh [ __ ] himself at a school ceremony
oh okay
we could easily get sean on the phone to
verify well no uh
whoever screened him says he provided
proof
name of school and student id
uh okay interesting
um let's do the ads and then we'll we'll
see what
we'll see what he has to say about the
i'm not sure that that necessarily is a
call we need to take
like he knows my he's my brother's
student which is fine right
i'm very intrigued you are of course you
are he just said he [ __ ] his pants i
mean
we like that i mean
there's a certain level of pain that
leads up to that you know it's a painful
shame you want the whole drama leading
up to it i want to feel some tears
all right thank you to
curology
hey
hey hey listen guys if you've been
opting out of skincare i get it
i have always avoided skin care routines
because i've just found it to be
first of all deciding on the products is
a pain in the ass or then putting the
time in is the whole thing
gerology
takes the annoying parts of the skin
skincare routine
and they basically they customize a
prescription formula with reactive
ingredients picked for you to help
tackle your skin care needs whether that
may be trying to take control of acne or
if acne is no longer your top skin
concern
it might be fine lines dark spots
occasional breakouts or clogged pores
all you got to do is start by answering
questions online about your skin and if
it's a good fit curology will match you
with a licensed dermatology provider who
will get to know your skin and uh
subject to a consultation you'll get a
customized prescription cream to be
stripped
straight to your door
you know what i've got is the
cleanser which is super gentle doesn't
strip the oils out then you've got the
dermatology prescribed cream that's
formulated specifically for your skin
you send them a photo of your face so
they kind of can see up close what's
going on there
and finally the moisturizer it's a
three-part routine you do it every day
and
i mean it feels great it really does you
don't have to think about it dude
exactly it's a no-brainer you can start
your curology journey just like i did
with a free 30-day trial at curology.com
h3 if prescribed just pay five dollars
for shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com h3 to unlock your free 30-day
trial thank you to curology
maybe take uh alfredo out again
they they just went out and they went
they went poopy and the the whole deal
what's wrong with you buddy that's what
i was thinking too because he
he was kind of jumping up on me
to say hi to ela um
shannon
do a little ela drop in
yeah maybe he needs to go again running
when you pulled out maybe he does have
to go yeah there's something up with him
he's definitely trying to tell us
something all right sugar you want to go
with them
nope
you okay
thank you to hello fresh
well freddy is just
a shredder
hello fresh
hello fresh
is the america's number one meal kit you
get measured fresh ingredients with
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door skip the
grocery line skip the stores and count
on hellofresh to make home cooking easy
fun and affordable
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit baby
the heart the fall harvest is officially
on with hellofresh count on seasonal
recipes like pumpkin cinnamon rolls
friendsgiving ready sides as well as
fresh high quality ingredients that
travel from the farm to your front door
in less than a week what the freak is oh
we got a photo
the infamous uh that is
uh just a photo of what are you showing
me it's just
yeah but
they
what does that have to do with hello
fresh they just said pumpkin cinnamon
rolls is one of the things you can get
but that's not the hell of fresh made
pumpkin cinnamon roll typed hello fresh
pumpkin cinnamon roll and this is what
came up
oh it is yeah
that looks bomb
it just looked like a generic photo well
just show the infamous ian soup all
right i'll show the information we gotta
get some new hello fresh out here though
well they sent us a bag and we made them
yeah no i know that's what i'm saying
because you know they support the show
and we love that
but anyway
there's the infamous av burrito and the
infamous ian's soup
which we love
those rolls look amazing
uh
it's so it's super fun you cook it at
home you get fresh pre-measured
ingredients you get the instructions you
get information about your food it's
just it's a wholesome experience it's
delicious it's nutritious it's hello
fresh and here's the best part
if you go to hellofresh.com h3tv14
and use code h3tv14
you're gonna get up to 14 free meals
including free shipping guys
go once again to hellofresh.com
and use the code h3tv14 for up to 14
free meals including free shipping uh
thank you thank you to hello fresh
america's number one meal kit
[Music]
we're rocking out baby
all right
see if there's any other calls to take
real fast before we
two video submissions to make ethan
laugh not asking for money just want to
see want anything to see him
wait do you see this one was in a faze
clan music video and wanted to talk
about experience interacting with the
members that's kind of interesting story
about cav cav falling down the stairs no
okay let's try that matilda
you got me interested in matilda you saw
kavkav fall down the stairs in manhattan
yes so um
i had an internship i'm from new york
city and i was working in
midtown manhattan
one day as i'm leaving work um
it's in this really fancy complex and
there's a bunch of like
town cars with little like trailer signs
on them and like security looking dudes
with trailer badges
um and so
i was
i was very excited and i was hoping that
i would
you know get to see
the man himself and i kind of waited in
the sort of park that's right outside um
i don't find my office i guess
he walks down these stairs they're kind
of long and then just kind of almost
face plants and then like slams into
this like huge security dude
um
and i
legend
well that's fascinating uh
how long ago was this
that was in july i think there was i
ended up looking it up and there was a
um
one of the boxing events in
madison square garden
well that is a fascinating story matilda
and uh it's hard to believe but uh
wow i believe her
why would why would you disbelieve that
i believe it but it's just such an
incredible story that uh
i actually just found a picture of it
of it happening
i don't think that's capcom oh no you
don't think that's it yeah so so did he
fall he fell into the bodyguard did he
got up was he was he uh dignified did
you see hair fall out of his head um
would uh tell me what was there any
other details that may be interested in
here or or we have the whole story i
can't actually see much because of his
inferior hairline um right that's so i
can i mean i can be more specific about
where it was um
but yeah i'm seeing i'm getting
tomatoes
alrighty thank you matilda appreciate
the call
thank you take care now
all right
all right
um
there's dude the subreddit is just a
total [ __ ] show lately
lately
i don't know like if you go to the
subreddit right now it's all memes about
here let me go to the subreddit it's all
memes about
copy pasta [ __ ] posting anyone who
applies ethan and ela have more than a
friendship need to grow the [ __ ] up i
actually
there's an album i put together an album
oh it's in here anyone implies zach and
abe have anything more than friendship
need to grow the [ __ ] up anyone that
implies that dan and shredder have more
than i guess this all this was the
original post anyone who implies that
olivia and abe have more than a
friendship need to grow the [ __ ] up like
i was not even aware me neither i opened
the subreddit this morning i was just
like what is happening were you aware
that this was some kind of thing
maybe
i saw a few stupid comments but then it
became more prevalent on reddit
but people really think that there's
some kind of thing i mean i mean
we're we're all professionals here not
to mention avey's obviously married and
yeah i mean olivia and lena were reading
them laughing about it on friday it's
just ridiculous i mean i know whoever's
commenting this must not have a friend
of the opposite sex i don't know hey
fred
he's gonna carry like a baby i'm gonna
come well i'm sorry that oh a b and
olivia had to be
subject to that kind of scrutiny but at
least it's turned into something anyone
who
i don't know what it is but anyone that
implies that ryan kevin and harvey
weinstein have anything more than
friendship need to grow the [ __ ] up
the one about me and ab is kind of true
you know we have more than just the
friendship
yeah oh then it's not true because it's
not true excuse me oh so should i remove
that one
uh yeah i mean we're pretty public about
how we feel about each other i mean i'm
looking well i mean
you know you you basically sucked on his
nipples last week so that was spiritual
experience
anyway uh this is the other meme that is
uh infecting the subreddit and i take
cross with all of it
memes about me ethan's the type of guy
who tells the person waiting to use the
bathroom after him it's all yours man
no i'm the type of guy
that stays in the stall until
everybody's gone to leave because i'm so
embarrassed
country and when i used to work a day
job i would stay in that stall for as
long as it took wait that won't come and
it's all you need
i think zach's that could do it
zach's the type of dude to tell a
cashier have a good day and think he
made her i do i do do that exactly
ethan's the type of guy who says cha cha
cha when singing happy birthday
why these people think they know me so
well
ethan's the type of guy to have an apron
that says kiss the chef on it
what's so funny about these
and even why are you laughing love
i just think it's funny that you're
being annoyed oh really
he kissed his old nasty pig
shut up
he's the type of guy to rub his hands
together and say all right let's dig in
when dinner is ready
[Laughter]
it's not true it's nothing there's
nothing accurate about me this next one
is the one that even the type of guy
that sniffed the air and float when he
smells a pie
i don't even like pie it's like some
disney [ __ ] cartoon [ __ ] i don't
even like pie
what's so funny
the mental image is so crystal clear for
some reason of like with the with the
the scent lines like kind of emanating
out and then you kind of turn into a
snake as you're floating through the air
and yeah
ethan the type of guy to pronounce
karate karate
i just pronounced it right when i was
reading the sentence it doesn't make any
sense
ethan the type of guy who says
when he snores
that one got me
why it's funny i sleep on my side i
don't even snore
it's just it's i'm just picturing you as
like a as a looney tunes character and
for some reason it just really works
just
yeah well it's not true okay and i want
to put that out there
ethan's the sort of guy to pull out a
comically large spoon when ela lets him
have only a spoonful of ice cream
i don't own a comically large spoon and
i don't even eat ice cream that often
okay
ethan the type of guy to ask the
drive-thru workers to remake his drink
with less ice
no that's not that was
that might be the one thing on here i
may have done
when i was younger oh
god less ice please
uh
eat what is this one smash that like
button says no more mr nice guy when
he's angry
says i bet these plants are loving this
when it rains
says thank you when siri gives him
directions third one for sure
ethan the type of guy who says just
going to squeeze right by you when
passing someone in an aisle
what's funny love what's funny about
that
hey why are you picking on me because
you never laugh and all of a sudden
you're giggling uh i've no i don't
squeeze by people
i don't know what half of these means
i'm just laughing because everyone
else's it's just some like it's a boomer
reaction to a lot of these things ethan
klein's the kind of guy to be late to
his own podcast
not today
not today early three early three
that pie one i saw over the weekend and
i just like couldn't stop giggling at it
i don't know what do you mean you don't
like pie what is that i just find pies
to be an inferior dessert
compared to other alternatives i mean
just categorically i just yeah
categorically i don't like pies
pie is such a too gooey
you know i'll take a cake i'll take an
ice cream it's all goo
it's all goo
name a pie
banana cream gooey
cheese pie
cheese pie
that's not a real pie
depends who you guys got pie in the name
what like a cheesecake
like bakery cheese pie are you talking
about like a cheese danish because pie
cheese
comes back it all comes back to the
zaatar and the uh labne
labone pie that does sound gooey though
regardless i do think apple pie is
overrated i will give you that oh my god
apple pie such it's like bro
why even bring that what are your
thoughts on pumpkin pie
it's okay
i tolerate it
the [ __ ] man arby's has the best pies on
the go the apple pie
um
uh facebook is down
couch guy debate oh this is gonna be
good
for those of you who don't spend a lot
of time on tick tock this may come
as news to you
but there is a ravenous debate going on
right now
regarding this video uh-oh the seemingly
non-video i'm excited to get into this
because i came in this morning and
opened the dock and this was in here and
i was like ooh controversy here we go
i did a little ethan move where i rubbed
my hands together never done that all
years bud okay can someone uh so grab me
a saudi yeah even the type of dude to
say saudi
i don't see any problems
but yeah i watched this video and i was
i
i still don't understand why what is
notable about this video okay i'm going
to break it down because i've watched
all of it i think part of the
joke is that it's so
innocent it's so innocent but there is a
lot of interesting details to unpack
okay a lot of thank you very much jimmy
what is that this is a lid if you want
oh
whoa aby just gave me a
soda pop lid
yeah so nothing flies in it y'all have
ever seen this before
oh yeah yeah he bought a set of those
for the office
we had the fly issue oh [ __ ] which by
the way has been mostly resolved yeah i
think yes we're winning the war yeah i
think we are winning the war
uh uh
i
it's live could i please get a glass
with ice and not too much eyes you are
the you are that type of guy i love that
thank you so much
hate to do that i usually
would type something on discord
but uh here we are yo somebody i know
we're moving off this topic but real
quick somebody pointed out pizza pie
that's a pie now that's a [ __ ] pie
i'll i'll eat that pie any day of the
week
he's never been in the pizza are we
really calling pizza pie i i do all the
time
yeah i know but pete is pizza a pie i
mean let's be honest here
i love pizza and i love pizza definition
of pie let's see let's see yeah let's
define pipe a baked
dish okay you do bake a pot a pizza
of fruit or meat and vegetables all
three of those things go on pizzas
typically with a top typically but not
always
top and base
of pastry well would you
call pizza dough a pastry no
it's not it's bread
it's definitely not a pasta
so it's the crust that yeah i think it's
it's the pastry crust that disqualifies
now i know the chicagoans call their
pizzas pies i can't ever say
that i've ever had a pizza that
qualifies as a pie and i would love to
the chicago deep dish i think is easier
to classify as a pie based off of
how it's made it's pretty good i tried
it once the chicago deep dish
and to me it was just a shitload of
crust
if you can find a good place for chicago
and you want to order it right now i'll
try it right now i know the best one
make it happen right no place here in
l.a that maybe not in la but they'll
ship it from chicago what the [ __ ] how
does that help us exactly they freeze it
and they you got me so excited they
freeze it and they ship it
i've had it i know a chicago place too
if you guys want
yeah well i know a place you know sri
lanka that makes good pizza too but i
don't say i don't see that helping
anyone you want the authentic pizza
i know a great place in chicago do you
know good place in l.a because that's
where we are right now a lot of people
on the side are agreeing chicago pizza
is definitely a pie yeah so bring me
bring me one of those and we'll rate it
right now okay there's got to be a place
in la that has rel i know anybody from
chicago will be over it's
all the same so what is it
okay let's do a pizza review today right
now
and this has nothing to do with me just
wanted to eat pizza i guarantee it
deep dish check this garden in los
angeles
anyway are you did you really
is this a serious suggestion
what did you send
that is not authentic chicago ej's pizza
wait wait what is this is this a
problematic place no it's a patrol it's
like it's like a chain it's like
it's like sending it's like oh you're
talking the chain
why don't you just suggest domino's
that's not what i was talking about the
one in chicago bro he sent
bj's restaurant
that was not the one i was referring to
to be honest though that probably may
not be about like compared to what's out
there
people are i'm doing a little research
to see if people are suggesting a place
in l.a uh love just posted i don't want
to dox him
yeah but while you look that up let's
talk let's let's get into the couch guy
actually let's not let's talk about
pizza more
let's let's google pizza everybody keep
saying geo
george don't say the name because
oh well it's too late they're gonna get
well i don't even know if we're gonna
order it from this place sam's looking
into it right now
so let you guys tell me
when i think okay so like that's a pizza
pie but that's not what you guys are
thinking of
like this like this this you know right
something like that yeah it's pretty
pile-like right wait is it like this
no that looks like a lasagna pizza okay
yeah just chicago deep dish
this is all a farce
why can't oh my god
thank you
[Music]
chicago
deep dish
a lot of people say no to that geo
dano's player okay so here we've got um
something like this is it is this yeah
that's oh yeah
so put the sauce on top
and then it's like super thick and with
like a [ __ ] ton of water what [ __ ] go
have you ever had like this like actual
chicago apparently not
i've never been to chicago so i i
haven't had like the official thing but
i've been to places that do this style
so that looks pretty good
yeah i can't say i've ever had this
style somehow
bj's there's there's two really popular
places in chicago pizza uno and pizza
duo there's also server like this oh
really gino's in chicago do you know any
places in like uh dubai maybe that could
be helpful to me right now there's
alibaba's pizza dubai
but they cook at chicago style yeah
would you put lebanon on that ap
they're not talking about on anything
anything all right anyway
so
back to
the couch gate the couch guy
so this girl posted a video of her
surprising her boyfriend
at college
it's a short clip
very short
she goes in greets him
but people started to notice small
details in the video
and determined that he's been cheating
on her
i i guess let's see
yeah i watched it like five times and i
was like i do not understand what is
notable you guys gotta go find the
evidence videos of people pointing out
like first there was one about the hand
on the back
and then it was debunked
as the dude's watch
and then there's the phone passing i
i've i'm deep on on couch yeah olivia
knows she says the phone
oh we can't play the music so here's i
feel like we should get olivia down here
because i feel like she'll know yeah
olivia should come olivia come on down
yeah so
here she comes in
she's surprising him first he doesn't
seem that excited to see her uh i guess
maybe which is what got people
suspicious right
but let's let's run it back
so here they come in
what the first thing people freaked out
about which i'll go back
that start this whole conspiracy off is
that here you'll notice there's a hand
on his back you see that
is that it is that well well hold on
okay
so and then the girl this girl next to
him scoots away from him immediately
she scoots away
see she scoots she scoots
okay
now
and then the other thing that's really
suspicious here that people are pointing
out
is that the phone watch right here
he grabs the phone wait where's the
phone grab here here look at this look
at this sussy
phone this sassy baca
why the [ __ ] does this always happen to
me on tick tock
i didn't do anything man
golly
i gotta reopen the link and everything
our page is so cursed
so uh
yeah
so let's try this again
so there's a moment here which a lot of
people are pointing out which is kind of
suspicious you guys tell me watch in his
lap watch closely in his lap he grabs
the phone from the girl next to him
oh
you see that right here
watch watch this he grabs the phone
on the table no no no
cross his lap watch his right hand
[Music]
see he reaches in like that sus
and brings his phone out from the other
girl
who handed it to him
okay see that did you see
how
now my question about that and maybe you
can help explain olivia is
why
does her having his phone incriminate
him of anything
i think it's more the handoff of the
phone
because like he crouches over
and then he like very slowly takes it
from her and i think there's also this
thing where it's like if you're flirting
you're looking at stuff on your phone
together
but what i think is the weirdest part is
that when she walks in he doesn't like
jump up he kind of looks embarrassed
right
but so if we're going back you guys
don't understand how much
uh videos and billions of views have
been about couch guy slander but the
thing that first of all
i'm i'm people are going to hate me for
this but i feel like maybe couch guy's
innocent
i mean it's all
pretty innocent i just think it's super
fun i i do bad for him i mean the amount
of [ __ ] that this guy's gotten as a
result of this people take this [ __ ] so
seriously but you remember when the
people like influencers are famous no no
it was a random video posted a tick doc
that absolutely exploded this is
psychotic there's nothing wrong in this
video so it is it is
it's funny when until you realize that
it's actually ruining these people's
lives
yeah that's true what the [ __ ] but wait
now here's something that so you
remember when everyone said said oh
there was a hand on his back
well
okay that got debunked so everyone's
like dude the girl's hand is on his back
and then she scoots away from him but
here you realize mother of god scroll up
scroll up oh scroll up over yeah well
now i'm curious what this is
let's not well hold on i'm curious what
this is dad
yeah what what's wrong with this
well you just never know on tick tock
what you're about to see man
my feet are though
okay
so what you'll notice is there's a guy
with a watch on
in the kitchen
okay
so here you can see his watch clearly
see his watch yeah so what it actually
is
is the guy's watch
on his wrist
you see
it's his watch and it makes it look like
a hand there was never a hand on his
back wow wow
wow
so all this left people were so invested
in the hand
that they blew up this whole guy's life
and now that they'll hand they've lost
the hand all they have is this phone
handoff and his lukewarm reception is
that right olivia
i think the phone has some pretty hot
reception
well what if the phone was just sitting
sitting in the it's just sitting in the
crack of the cushion
okay there's a phone somewhere we know
there's a phone between him and the girl
next to him somewhere i think she's
definitely holding it
okay i don't know if it's no no he
grabbed it now let's say he wanted to
grab it with his left hand that would be
awkward grabbing it with the right
almost makes more sense that's why it
looks like he's trying to hide something
because he like leans over to cover
himself grabbing his phone let's
let's examine closely
okay as we fast forward
he does have kind of a shit-eating grin
on his face i won't deny that he's not
jumping up to greet her like you would
expect and he's like oh i'm being
recorded too like what the [ __ ] i think
that that's the main point he's not
ecstatic
he does look like he's been caught yeah
yeah for sure i mean even if it's just
maybe him flirting with a girl maybe
[Laughter]
that helps me
awesome i take antiseptic
our feed is so crazy bro next time he
does that you should switch off ian
because i just i'm fearing that we're
just gonna get something insane one of
these times and get in trouble right we
are live
it's kind of the excitement
okay so now here's where the big issue
comes up
his right arm goes cross lap he's
reaching for his phone the question is
is he's reaching it from the girl
is he reaching it
because it's on the couch why does he
immediately reach for his phone anyway
why does he need his phone you would
think that his first instinct would be
to greet her you would think that yet
his first instinct is to grab his phone
why
here he reaches reaches obscured
obscured back into focus he's leaning
forward like he's hiding his boner or
something
i'm curious when the last time they saw
each other well we don't have any
information except this video
i feel i mean that this is all the
evidence if your girlfriend you haven't
seen i don't know a year comes a time
i'm assuming he hasn't seen her in a
while because they did a whole hubbub
about it yeah and you're just like oh
you're here
right that's [ __ ] sussy yeah
it's like a burden well hold on let's
let's finish examining this
why is he leaning forward so much
maybe he just did have a
a woody
yeah yeah i just what i see is it i
gotta stand up now i definitely it
reminds me of trying to conceal a bone
that's [ __ ] is he wearing why is he
that's the first thing that you've
pointed out that actually does kind of
make that why is he have a boner though
wait hold on exactly is he cheating he's
not i mean just kidding sometimes you
get random boners it happens it does
seriously it does no i swear to god for
some reason i always didn't imagine the
timing
but this is a call that would be
important sitting next to a girl i feel
like there's some provocation for having
an erection he has gray sweatpants too
just want to throw that out i don't know
yeah great sweatpants season
[Laughter]
wait a b you still pop boners like that
i'm sorry is that what you just said
like it happened you said it happened in
math heaven and math oh i think it has
something to do with the temperature
i always try to figure it warm it was
cold but all the cold weather did it i
don't know it was weird
so the uh the weird time
it would happen to me on the bus like
yes every day on the bus but but that
but i was in middle school this is a
college student right sitting amongst
people yeah
i think he was probably just embarrassed
well hold on see how we so olivia i'm
going to challenge you a little bit
here the phone comes why is everybody
saying hair tie wait hold on does he
have a hair tie on his wrist that's hers
oh that was the other piece of i didn't
even see that i was seeing a lot of
people in the chat just sit were saying
hair tie okay so i'm i'm familiar with
the hair tie theory as well okay
so apparently
there's also a hair tie
on his wrist that appear that people are
theorizing as the other girls but hold
on we didn't finish analyzing the phone
here he leans forward where does the
phone come from where does the phone
come from
where
where
she slides it to him and he grabs it
with his right hand that he's covering
what if he is or so maybe he was like
what is that incriminating what if he
that's what i don't know it was showing
her something on his phone yeah but then
why is the handoff so
that's what i mean it's not really it's
just i don't know and dude's popping
boners phone that's guilty but he didn't
try to hide the phone he put it right in
front of her
yeah but maybe he was trying to make it
seem like the phone was there all day
don't you think it'd be more discreet if
she just put it down on the couch
absolutely but you think you messed up
we do things in uh
okay but now let's examine the hair tie
theory
so the final theory here
is that he's wearing the girl's hair tie
now i don't ever really do that i've
never done that
but he's got it people are saying a hair
tie but it could easily just be a
bracelet too
is this for sure around his i see
yeah that could just be a watch or a
bracelet or something are we sure this
is a hair tie he could definitely damn
it
wait why are people so sure it's a hair
tie
i love boiling i don't think they are
sure i think they're just assuming
they're trying to find the worst
see yeah i mean well okay here we can
get a pretty good look at it let's see
i mean it could just be like a live
strong or whatever brace it could be a
small bracelet it could definitely be a
bracelet i love to think that it's a
hair tie though
you know why do you wish a lot of the
situation i like to keep the fantasy
going of it all
okay let's watch the whole thing in
entirety now
and uh come to a conclusion
okay
here we are
there's music playing so we have a muted
obviously
but she's like hey baby i'm here
and he's like i mean his mannerism i
think says more than anything where he's
like oh [ __ ]
you know
so there you have it i also just want to
add
this factor is
based off of how everybody else in the
room is acting it seemed like everyone
else was aware that this surprise was
coming
like all the friends
you think so yeah let's watch that again
certainly the people there's people with
her and his homie just let her in
right that's that's true
homie on the left and the white t-shirt
it's kind of like an oh [ __ ] type thing
oh yeah i was i agree with zach i would
argue that they're surprised that
they're arriving really because no one
like pulls out their phone to record or
anything well you think one of his
friends would be like yo
your girlfriend's here
what they were trying to set him up to
get busted no trying to give him a tip
off
right but by not tipping him off
no who what homie would do that
he's just so unenthusiastic it's crazy
yeah he like waits for her to come up to
him and what is
this video has 4.4 let me tell you how
many views this video has now
this was uploaded by the girl
i mean she uploaded it so okay
you know
let me find the original video
she like turned into a youtube celebrity
now 53 million views okay
that just to show you and then all these
updates
oh here they are together so people are
going back in their history
and dissecting everything like this
video poster before the viral one has
six million views here they are
how long before the other videos this
was on the 19th september 19th oh so
that
let me just have the bracelet on in that
video oh in
he does the hair theory is debunked
immediately
well done dude you guys well done like
all these like tick tock detectives and
ian just debunked that whole theory
do they go to the same college is that
what this is all about well hold on well
that wouldn't make any sense
so this was on the 19th
the the viral video was posted
two days later so why is she even
why are they doing this it could be in
the drafts yeah one before it could have
been that's true but also it's tick-tock
everyone just [ __ ] okay well hold on
if it's a draft thing let's go back to
the video before it
this one the this is from the fourth
so you could be right it could be a
draft video
and they're not even together in this
one either the last video of them
together
you know what that's a pretty good
theory because i don't see them together
it could have been in the drafts and it
could be like oh i missed my boyfriend
yeah but that's a pretty recent
last video of them together
uh
is
uh here's one
this is from
yeah this is too long ago no look it's
no click on that one look what it says
124. no no but look at the captions okay
take up with rob because i miss him see
this is like
it was probably that was them when they
were together after she surprised him
and then she got the footage of the
surprise and then posted it i agree said
they were separated for a while
but also they they basically is proof
that they
were hanging out and being together
after this
giant expose
this is insane
yeah it's really insane what we're doing
right now like i'm not doing it i'm
reporting on a cultural phenomenon 53
million views tick tock is all talking
about
but we're help i feel like i need to
defend couch guy to an extent here
because first of all the bracelet thing
completely debunked not a hair tie yeah
so the hound thing is debunked
the the hair tie thing is debunked all
that's left is the foam which let's be
honest
total speculation it also could just be
like sometimes when someone has a
boyfriend and you're friends with them
if their girlfriend who you don't know
comes in you're like all right i'm gonna
like he's trying to i don't want to like
he doesn't want to be cringy yeah and
also like i don't want to threaten her
in any way if like that's how she feels
i'm about to meet her i want her to know
that we're friends the part that i don't
get is the reaction if you haven't seen
your girlfriend in that long wouldn't
you be ecstatic
maybe he's in shock
but you never know
it's not evidence of anything but here
here oh mute it so here they are
mother of frick
okay
here they are hanging out
they're been reunited five days ago
okay so they're just having a good time
is robbie content though
[ __ ] you candy stock hey that comment
has 300 000 likes yeah and who are you
to comment freaks
300 000 likes what time absolute [ __ ]
freak [ __ ] right there
yeah wow is robbie content though
so here can you guys find some of the
deep theory videos because i wanted to
show you
i have something
that's much
much more work oh my god okay before you
feel too bad dan they're selling merch
okay since you guys seem to really love
couch guy tik tok my dad thought it
would be funny and a good boy to
actually make t-shirts
so this is the couch guy t-shirt they
are
24.99 and there is free shipping but
they come in this is hustling i mean
it's free
blue orange this is i'm not going to
hold that again
we should all get one we should get a
different color check out treasures
let's support them yeah nobody's gonna
care about this in 24 hours we'll be
over i think
i would love a t-shirt we may not we
probably won't get these for like a
month exactly and then we're gonna be
like why the [ __ ] did we buy these
they're just being mass produced by her
dad
you know what though
it's hilarious to me this is her most
recent vid
she's hustling that couch guy meme
what were you showing me about keemstar
somebody on discord squid blue shout out
just sent me this
yup
and said dan
tell me if it doesn't look like keem is
watching ethan in the background of the
twitter video that you showed earlier oh
interesting
here's our own sky drama is this h3tv
it's impossible is this h3tv wait did he
just post that on twitter this is the
video we watched earlier of him
complaining about his algorithm but that
was from okay but that was from from a
few days ago it was from i guess that's
true isn't it but that does not look
like h3 tv to me does it after dark
maybe
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
it's got the mic
oh it's so hard to tell well is there
any other frames go to the video and see
if we can find more conclusive evidence
interesting
okay now we have our own couch guy
theory
right
here i'm pulling up the original video
is it this one no
where did it go
are you you got it i got it right there
it's right there i was doing it for
ethan what happened nothing i've been
deleting stuff after we go through it in
the show and then and then it's gone and
look how fast it's with peace and love
you don't you i'm you
thank you though i mean i like the
theory of it
it's good it is good to do but it's not
not while we're still going through that
okay okay here's the video
okay this so oh this doesn't let you
zoom though look it just makes the
player bigger and smaller it's not
helpful at all
well uh
if you're on soon oh jesus okay
if you don't full screen you can zoom
it's very weird
okay still won't let me go not really
helpful okay well let's just go just go
normal size and let's just go frame by
frame and see
if keemstar is a secret h3 stand
roll
yes roll it i don't think it is
oh it's paused it's paused or is it
yes it is pause you know what i think
it's the news or something yeah i know
why they think it though because i see a
purple
like lower thirds and i see green in the
background yeah right i want to believe
he is watching it too bad that would
have been great
the guy who sent it to me just messaged
again and said dude who else leans in
their chair like that i agree that the
posture is very easy one there's no so
many people have the nerve
yeah i agree but i'm on the wrong side
that's right exactly unless unless the
agent is sometimes when you talk to the
crew
i'm on the this i'm like here that would
mean i was like yeah sometimes you well
no
i mean my microphone i can't go past
this all right fine keemstar is in an h3
stand
trust me i want to believe it more than
i know i really wanted to believe but
unfortunately i don't think
i don't think so back to couch guy
the boyfriend made a response video in
the what is this
the comments are so mean to the poor guy
people are i love he says
i love her she's the best hashtag couch
guy
[Music]
you're welcome for getting you off
berries and cream tick tock
but remember not everything is true
crime
don't be a parasocial creep get some
fresh air take care that's what he said
blood boiling whoa whoa look at that top
comment and tell me these people are not
oh no yeah no people started like
they're trying to ruin his life gaslight
her and us yes king you can pull this
off gasps like her and us [ __ ] the
minimal effort putting into defending
her too
not the hoodie the last girl was wearing
wait
no no no hold on let's verify that
let's verify that because again we we
have to we're pro couch guy here we take
every claim seriously so he's just real
quick people the chat is pointing out
selfie mode
on that keem video everything's flipped
so you would have been on the other okay
so so then that does line up so he is
a stand
i'm not convinced you want to pull it
back up
i'm busted
we have two conspiracies going on
simultaneously it's a lot with a lot of
little intermissions of um
these random tick tocks
of people dancing and stuff
well there's another video he put out on
twitter that same day like right after
and it's unpaused and it's not
sorry guys okay debunked
so first of all what the [ __ ] what is
this story are you high bro
now this is just straight slander at
this point they're saying that this girl
so he's wearing a purple hoodie right
you
see nobody in here is wearing a purple
hoodie
like and that comment has 30 000 likes
this is
what are you guys talking about
this girl now it's this girl he's not
even next to her she's on the opposite
side of the couch
is he cheating on everyone in that room
i don't get it
there's the girl next to him is not
wearing a purple hoodie
okay
comments minimal effort not the hoodie
the last girl was wearing she's the best
that's something i would say if i had a
favorite teacher literally no meaning
i mean this is a lot you guys
my bad
i don't know how that ended up there uh
his caption feels like he friend zoned
her
so yeah
uh
apparently she's still with the dude and
they celebrated national boyfriend day
over facetime
can you not find any of the just hashtag
couch guy i want to find some of the
beautiful mind videos that have been
made just to show i sent like three of
them oh they're in discord yeah
here they are celebrating national
boyfriend day
uh posted by her
something
[Music]
so they're on
facetime
[Music]
suspicious
he's using the laptop to facetime
because some girl has his phone top
comment
donut date him
every time i check for the breakup it
keeps getting worse
pretty incredible
and then it's so just to show you guys
the kind of videos that blew this whole
thing up
here's one
uh
yo look what i found 160 000 likes
so here yeah look what i found
one more time
i know y'all seeing that
that's straight up
hold on
that's a hand it's
do you see what i'm saying this is the
hysteria they're really literally trying
to ruin this poor guy's life and it's
not even true yep
um here's another one
so i don't know i'm pro couch guy i
think couch guy is innocent
here's one with 400 000 likes
i've watched this video way too many
times but look at the beginning here it
looks like her hand is on his back like
that looks like a thumb and maybe a
finger
like house us and then she scoots over
not once
but
twice she scoots over twice how suspect
making
there's very little to go off here
but i just want to show you guys what
tick tock's been up to all weekend long
because this is a huge story this is
like new york times front page [ __ ]
one more one more here we were able this
one has 1.6 million likes a theory video
hold on i gotta check the views on this
theory video
kim castro
wine girl
okay so this theory video has 14 million
views i'm invested okay
14 million views on a couch guy theory
video dan
people are gonna get hobbies
okay let's zoom in a little bit
rewind
you can see the phone in her hand right
there you can see the case right there
boom
boom
means forward give me more freaking
functions right here oh my gosh there it
is the phone is open on the camera same
case but
i mean
bounce bounce bounce
pause okay let's zoom in a little bit
look at the comments she blocked me
follow for more detective work
it's it's it's a lot it's a lot it's a
lot
it's a lot
so i don't know i'm not convinced click
on tim castro's account real quick you
want to see what she's been up to yeah i
want to i want to just start an
investigation on her
try and get her fired from her job
jesus damn
i'm kidding obviously but this is like
why are people obsessed with the
following
oh my god i really didn't think this was
a big deal and thought everyone was
exaggerating but you seriously have the
best evidence and now i'm convinced here
we go
oh so it's evidence that there's a girl
there holding his phone there's like
five pixels in that no i think it's i
think i think it's right that there's
someone next to him here
that is holding his phone who he grabs
it from but i still don't understand how
that makes him
guilty
right
does that make him guilty if no
no
anyone want to chime in here and before
we close the case on this
i don't want to be wrong
oh god i think she's holding his phone
you don't think so
no
that's in his lap
i'd rather speak up and be wrong than be
muffled it's crazy wrong even the
parodies of this are getting crazy
amount of views yeah the parodies are
funny i'll give it that
people started doing
parodies where maybe you can find some
uh av i sent one right now yeah the
parodies are good where they're like
a girlfriend's visiting and like a bunch
of like dudes walk out of the room
i'm sure couch guy is going to be a hot
halloween costume this year
that couch guy yeah
if he had something more distinctive on
then
but here surprising my girlfriend in
college
[Laughter]
you gotta find the one that was pretty
funny you gotta find the one where all
the dudes come out of the room that was
[ __ ] that was very good um we gotta
do our other two ads it's been i did
some research on that i'll uh
thank our other two sponsors of today
which is me on these me
are you afraid of the dark
well then you might want some
glow-in-the-dark underwear because me
undies halloween just dropped and
there's one collection you don't want to
ghost it's this one they've got five new
prints to turn up the terror and you
should summon them before it's too late
listen it's not just about the spooks
and the goofs with me undies it's about
the softest most breathable underwear in
the game
it's made from
micro modal it's breathable it's cozy
it's sustainable
i'm a big fat guy
i cannot handle the disintegrated
underwear that i've been carrying around
since high school anymore
i need grown-up underwear
uh there's better options guys there's
better options out there
get your spooky season up and haunting
with five new prints i see you my boo
tricks and treats lazy bones and lazy
pumpkins available in undies bra lit
socks loungewear and sizes extra small
through for xl
there's a lot of options to consider but
make a decision quickly because there's
somebody right behind you
they made me read that
yep you don't even have to think about
it dude that's true because with our
special offer me andy's has a for the
first time purchasers you get 15 off and
free shipping and they also promise that
if you're not satisfied with the product
for any reason you can return your order
for a full refund within 45 days that
means
stephen crowder what does it mean you
don't even have to think about it dude
no thinking required baby it's a
money-back guarantee so to get 50 off
your first order of the most comfortable
breathable crushing underwear not like
they could like
it doesn't crush your balls it like
like when someone does a good job you
crush it
make that clear
to get 50 off your first order free
shipping and 100 satisfaction guarantee
go to meandies.com
h3tv that's meundies.com
h3tv
thank you
and finally
you know them you love them it's
oral hygiene
is something i take very seriously
and quip changed the game for me one
thing i love about kwep soft bristles
i don't know
how
to tell you how hard it is to find
bristles that i like because even the
ones that are rated as soft are still
[ __ ] up my gums
yeah i gotta find like that very soft
but the best bristles i've found
straight up are on quip they're like
this special soft kind of rubber texture
it's still it cleans your teeth
perfectly like any toothbrush it's so
soft it doesn't really harm my gums i
like to brush my gums too you know the
dentist says you should do that
so other than having the beautiful soft
bristles what it does is an electric
toothbrush
and it it you know it pulsates every 30
seconds to tell you you're done with
that quadrant
making sure you get that two-minute
dentist recommended
perfect brush every time
you brush you know incidentally the
vibrating toothbrush is better than
non-vibrating dentists all kind of came
to a consensus on that as far as
toothbrush go man it's hard to be
equipped it's hard to beat the price too
quip is loved by over 7 million mouths
dude
that's a lot i gotta say that's
impressive
like i said it's uh vibrates every 30
seconds it's a lightweight it's sleek
there's no wires or bulky chargers
it's got a multi-use travel cover that
doubles as a mirror mount for less
clutter and it's got reusable handles
and a range of sleek metal hues
including the best selling all black and
all pink as well as bright plastic
colors
uh to make sure it pops
in your bathroom counter
so you can stay on top of your brushing
with the new smart motor track and
improve your brushing with free quip app
earn amazing rewards like refills free
refills products target gift cards and
more
beyond the brush quip has everything you
need to complete the routine for example
they have toothpaste now anti-cavity
toothpaste and mint and watermelon
and they also have floss
floss strings that expand to clean
reusable floss that replaces
over 150 disposable picks with every
refill
and i love their gum it's sugar-free has
a long-lasting flavor and dentists
actually say that uh
chewing gum after meals is great for
your mouth hygiene
um so there you have it
love them with stylish and affordable
electric toothbrushes they start at just
25
okay you won't be paying through the
teeth for better oral health
go to get quipped.com
h3tv right now and you'll get your first
refill for free that's your first refill
free at get quipped.com h3tv spell g-e-t
q-u-i-p dot com slash h3 it's quip the
good habits company
all right
yeah so um
um what is this
legit the pink is evila's shirt oh is
this our own conspiracy
oh somebody's saying it's ela someone is
saying so wait did you disprove it
because there's more theories here
um that keemstar is was watching h3 so
they're saying they're saying
that it's this frame
i don't see it
well they're [ __ ] right this does
look like me now i'm seeing me okay well
let me ask you this would h3tv have
purple graphics
that does look like me you guys
like i see myself here for sure
that could just be if he has it on tv
that could just be the like the
interface of like
i just said he put out another video
with the tv unpaused on the same day
which was you know close proximity to
that video so and it looked like
something it was something i'm going to
film it off can you show me that yeah
let's watch that
but you know dude
i see myself here i'm leaning here's the
mic
i mean i see it actually i do see it he
was probably enraged that our channel is
so successful bro
his is going to the [ __ ]
oh
easy
zack you're gonna curt you're gonna hex
our channel
[Music]
not like we didn't spend the first 30
minutes same basically
i sent in the discord all right so so
here we have more evidence to consider
in the matter
uh here's a submission
of the tv not paused
tensor
shut up
stop talking i'm just gonna mute him
yeah it looks like the news is playing
yeah this is like some other yeah that's
totally but this is
like an hour later roughly so
so he posted this one
when ela came in that was at the end of
h3tv so he would have finished the
episode and moved on to watching
something oh right because he's
in new york
uh
yeah so if he posted this at one it
would have been four which would be the
end of h3 tv but this is a friday
i mean after dark so when was the first
picture posted at what time
uh the first one is at 11 21. oh right
well but right what he's saying is
regardless he wouldn't have been
watching h3tv live he would have been
watching the vod right right
there's no such thing as a coincidence
i think it's me i think this person's
right
i mean i don't i was doubting it until i
s this looks unmistakable me right here
right and then when you see it with that
frame of that moment oh my god goodness
shout out to let leigh one two three
four i think
and and the original
finder here squid blue shout out to you
as well so i think couch guy
is innocent keemstar is guilty i gotta
go to the bathroom guys
okay so you want to carry the show down
sure i got a bunch of uh
donos in fact one [ __ ] insane one
maybe you should hear this even somebody
donated 500 british pounds
and you know what they said what they
said very simply
keem one star cavanaugh
team one star cavanaugh keem one star
kavanagh thank you so much dude joe
jerome newman 500 pounds
it's important he's like dunking on both
of them at the same time i thought it
was pretty good
uh what else we got keemstar looks like
pyramid head from silent hill but upside
down holy [ __ ]
hold on
[Music]
pyramid head
silent hill
[Laughter]
for anybody not familiar here is pyramid
head
from silent hill you flip him upside
down that's his beard
ah
yeah okay
very nice
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm such a good edit
what else
lucia
says uh
hey i think hey come in hot from small
little country slovenia right next to
italy fyi
are there any fupa troopers here from
the balkans
love you guys been following you from
the beginning papa bless yeah um
there's a decent amount i remember
talking to a fan in the members discord
once who was also from slovenia so
you're not even the only slovenian koopa
trooper
so we welcome
all of our
balkan fans
sorry what the [ __ ] there's a fly sorry
oh
chrissy i thought he shot at me no no
another one love from finland brought me
here my uh frenemies beanies
uh brought me here and my friend
frenemies beanie we're the only h3 fans
we know about shout out to the fan uh
fanny
also i love hassan love leftovers [ __ ]
yeah
thank you
what's the uh
what's the vibe between because you you
recently
pointed out that there's like kind of a
rivalry thing between denmark and swedes
right it was denmark that you said right
what's the vibe between the finns and
the swedes are you guys are you homies
uh
i mean we can all
hate each other a little bit but
i think sweden and finland are pretty
cool honestly for life
you hate each other like the way that
american canadians always hate each
other but then they're like honestly
pretty simple yeah and friends it's
probably pretty comparable okay fair
enough what about norway do you both do
finns and swedes hate on norway together
yeah yeah okay good
we i mean we all hate each other i think
at least sweden hates everyone
maybe it's just
i think there might be some like old
old since sweden has owned everything
before
no no they're not part of sweden anymore
you know oh i see
out on the oil in
in norway right right cool
take it for life
you know we we gave them the country
back and they don't give any oil and
then they don't get the oil back
typical norwegian man typical typical
norwegians
shout out to our norwegian fans
if you if we have any
what else we got take it for life
falcons stand up
okay
uh star backwards is rats there's no
such thing as a coincidence [ __ ]
wow
hit me with that [ __ ] conspiracy
let's hear that
uh
here it comes
oh yeah
there is no such thing as a coincidence
you know there's a picture i really want
to show
from our uh day yesterday at universal
oh yeah of ian and i but uh whatsapp is
still down so i can't pull it
up for
downloaded coincidences we could do it
on discord
can you send it to discord real quick
yeah but i want to do a little tease for
the audience but it's not an upcoming
project it's the one i took not the one
that's not here just fyi
it's okay it'll get the point across
it'll suffice it'll suffice all right
for sure also shout out to all the foot
soldiers that we ran into yesterday it's
really nice meeting you guys oh yeah
quite a few uh people spotted us even
with even with masks even with masks
they're universal was my girlfriend's
birthday so we went out there
oh people were uh
saying that we hate zach because he
wasn't there zach zach was invited he
just couldn't i was not invited i want
you to shut the [ __ ] up i want justice i
was not yeah
what about that spiritual moment we had
when i sucked your nips huh how about
that i was kidding you just made it
weird
no well kidding i was invited i had
another thing i had to attend but i do
appreciate the invite zach is too tall
for the rides that's what it is he's
just too big and we don't want to make
it awkward okay so i don't want to say
too much but
[Music]
still
we'll tease damn dude you say i'm the
clown goblin look who's using this
opportunity of ethan in the bathroom
promote what
i don't know what it is don't say i'm
not going to say
just saying
uh dan one
tyrell's flavor for
huh
i keep seeing somebody say this
i'm hoping this isn't like the uh
that trisha comment where i get baited
into saying something i don't understand
one tyrell's flavor for life
um anybody
got an idea no it's it's a play of the
figa for life so
i don't know it's about my pay grade
they keep saying take it for life i
don't know what i'm sorry i don't know
what that means i appreciate it well
think of the support though
uh is love a closeted kalmar unionist i
don't oh yeah
i don't know if there's anything bad
yeah yeah maybe don't know about the
good stuff okay don't don't
it's basically that
the whole nordic is right i've heard of
this yes but if there's anything bad to
that uh union i don't want it i only
want the good right hopefully that's not
like a uh
far right like
naughty 505 might be oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] 505
lock it up sorry guys play cool
take care of something
yep i got you so you guys went to
universal huh
we did we did are you talking about it
yeah a little bit
this is ian right right here
[Laughter]
i wish dude icon
iconic he does look like you it's
interesting
yo is that is that the lillard
uh no i don't believe matthew willard uh
works at university is
yeah this is this is it though so shout
out to the fams
that's a whole uh meme hole there
any interesting calls fbi raider house
do a twitter mishap
tough noodles did he already tweet about
the show
oh my god that's why he's leading he's
on the attack
will always be keemstar
ethan and eli klein are considering
changing their baby's name after
accidentally leaking it well here look
you guys bullied us yeah i've seen it
it wasn't an accidental leaf it was a
horrendous name you see people so mean
for now it's a conspiracy and a
horrendous name
wow
you guys don't think i could honestly uh
tell eli didn't like the baby name
uh olivia just dropped a little tidbit
here
from variety hour on discord olivia
the segment may be over but tell a b the
purple part of the image
is the youtube recommended section for
an after dark thumbnail the game thumb
in that
bring it up
interesting theory i mean i think we've
already concluded that it's i know but
this this would just drive it home
[Music]
this actually won me over because that's
a very good point okay so here we're
back i see me now
now where's the after dark
under the line
the purple that's what i was concerned
with
because we don't have purple graphics
for h3tv
but that makes sense what are you
showing
is that even part of the tv yeah
yeah below the tv well
no it's not
yeah right here
and then this is like the up next
recommended oh [ __ ] and that's that's
after dark can you find that [ __ ] what
is this
we were we were live on after dark when
this tweet was posted so it would make
sense that it was getting pushed with
the default
uh graphic
do you think that's the recommended
underneath or something i mean that's
that was what the
go ahead look sorry when you start or
when you pause on tv
uh the that bar pops up and there's a
bunch of uh suggested videos listen it's
it's definitely me now that i'm seeing
it
but my only concern is that's me too
zoomed in
and that's definitely me
i won't lie this is definitely me yeah
all right let's move on keemstar's stand
we all knew that anyway regardless of
this it's the hairline
and everything else
all right i want to watch some long-form
stuff there's some good long-form
content out there
user submitted videos this is fun
um let's see
the wendy williams cinematic universe
what there's like a bunch of videos in a
playlist
wendy williams except there's no pop
game
wait was that you or them zack that's me
so that's part one
if there's a well there's a windy part
two
[Applause]
hmm
[Applause]
are these all just
silent probably beam me up wendy
it's just the silent one dude
okay there's a flying uh shatner up to
space
they just announced today shannon is
going to his face on on bezos is right i
think all those kind of g's at his age
yeah he's 90 apparently he's going to
die in space the oldest person to go i
think
[Laughter]
oh no old man has gone before
bezos is trying to kill shatner hell yes
towards the end we have more longer form
videos like the cut style and yeah yeah
where uh there's teams keep scrolling
okay teachers guess who's high
seven seniors decide who gets a dolly by
the way i think some some deep dish
chicago style pizza is arriving in a
minute yes
sam just messaged me she said this pizza
weighs like 15 pounds
oh yeah
hell yeah hell yeah is there any like is
there any like viral vids that are out
right now that i should watch that
people are talking about on twitch stuff
like that uh
yeah that actually up at the top it's
not long but have you seen this stuff
from this new um final fantasy game
uh what which
if you go to the top it's uh
right here i just highlighted i'm saying
origin is shaping up to be the edges
video game of all time
i've even heard of this
everybody was there was a trailer for it
uh back in e3 that everybody was goofing
on because it was like really over the
top and they keep screaming about chaos
every like 10 seconds if you saw those
like chaos memes a couple months ago
anyways the demo for the game is out and
this part of it has been going viral all
over the place just a fairy tale
the darkness the beasts
this despair that eats away at people's
hearts it doesn't sound like it's easy
to blame a single thing for all of that
it gives people hope to think the world
can be saved with a single heroic deed
even if it's never that simple
so i decided to become a sacrifice
i offered myself to the darkness and
prayed to become chaos
hoping some band of heroes would defeat
me
and thus bring an end to this empty
dream [ __ ]
for really
[Music]
this is the new final fantasy
bro
i think it's always been this bad and we
were just kids
oh this one is beasts this is like a
spin-off uh to the main series or
whatever but yeah
i mean dialogue has always been horrible
in these games yeah that that's kind of
what i was saying about
when everyone was uh listen i said video
game plots are not good right you got a
lot maybe dialogue dialogue can i say
dialogue's not good just be careful
about double downing on this on this
opinion well it's supported here by one
of the biggest franchises in the world
it's like the most popular french video
game franchise and
what do we have before us
um i guess let's watch some cut stuff
is there anything new though however
people have seen all these a billion
types
guess who's high
i feel like i could tell
although it really depends how
frequently they use right i mean
somebody uses a lot
you can hide it pretty well with eye
drops
bro are you [ __ ] high right now it's
not me
what
talk about what
what update
oh yeah i reached i talked to banks you
guys
because there was a big debate about
last on friday was banks saying he was
making fun of me with jason nash
or was banks
saying they were doing h3 humor h3h3
humor
actually i talked to banks because we
were trying to bury the hatchet
and basically i said listen banks i
don't hate you it's just uh
you know
like i say being friends with keemstar
is is the worst i could say about him
and that's pretty bad
right
that's a terrible thing to say about
someone
and of course when you sit next to
keemstar and participate in you know
saying that you're infinitely smarter
and infinitely more successful than me
then of course i'm gonna goon you blanks
but i don't hate blanks
but anyway i asked him we talked a
little bit and i said
can you clarify if you were saying you
and jason were making fun of me
or h style jokes
he said
he said when we see each other
and slight me slightly mention you
occasionally
and it's funny because it's irl and
super irrelevant to the situation
like someone will be wearing an orange
beanie and we'll joke watch out it's
ethan
[Music]
h3h3 humor doesn't sound very funny
well
the point is i don't think he's he's not
complimenting my humor
yeah he's saying they're making jokes
like and i get he's like yo i'm not
we're not being super mean it's just
stupid like oh there's h3
you like the boogie man the buggy man
hey man you're his your name is in his
mouth you know you're the john wick of
the internet well i don't really
fantasize about
them talking about me but uh
so there's the clarification the big one
from banks and thank you to banks on a
personal level
once again do not hate banks
but obviously being friends with
keemstar is a crime against humanity so
you can't say like i was just following
orders at the end of the day
you are actively harming the human race
thank you
wow
all right so cut
all right teachers guess who's high
let me take a look at these guys
beforehand
i mean this guy's obviously high now
all right let's take a look
is he a teacher or a student he's high
[Music]
my name is brian i'm a high school
english teacher my name is emily i teach
new immigrants who are learning english
i am a youth services agent look at that
sweater
abstain from that question
every day i work with kids
1 000 and i know this
for a kind of fact because kids are
[ __ ] and i can say wait this guy
say that because i don't give a [ __ ]
damn
and then he took out his iphone and
started playing limp biscuit and walked
out of the room
oh yes
i do there's a proper place in time and
school is generally not it
is in trouble
uh
no they don't get in trouble their
parents do you know when you see someone
what's with this guy
get out of my car and then you also see
smoke coming out of it so my job is like
going up to them being like you can't do
that with your kid in the car i feel
like i shouldn't have to explain that
yeah that's the kind of school i work at
here are your new students
okay
what's your name jacob cool jacob nice
to meet you and how do you spell that
j-a-c-o-b is
yeah this guy looks high to me
i mean look at the eyelids bro he's like
i have some questions um what do
grapefruits have to do with grapes
uh
i don't think they have is this a joke
no it's an actual question oh um
i don't know what do they have to do
with grapes
so far all these teachers talk like such
teachers it's uh it's giving me anxiety
boomer ass back in school flashbacks
yeah this guy's high for sure i don't
know
i don't think he is does this look like
a step to you that yeah in general tends
to be misleading in my exact guy
definitely looks like a stoner looking
at this guy i'm calling it why is there
uh interstate in hawaii i don't know is
there an interstate anywhere you gotta
interstate this guy's so high he's so
[ __ ] what i think his eyebrow arch is
making him look high
to be honest no way i'm calling you're
just kind of like thinking about it too
logically i do not believe you are high
okay i don't get to find that
immediately i can't find out later this
is great okay who the [ __ ] this guy hi
wait i thought they were ratings like
they're just a grown ass man could be
college students like this guy's like
[ __ ] older than they are
i think he might be intoxicated
yeah think of the book i don't think
he's like
what's what
dude very much like they're like man
usually they this
perfume you think you're good at
catching your students uh
i do i like that do you get pleasure to
catch any students what dude an even
older dude on the left i'm sorry but
what is with this guy
i don't like it
i don't like it
i thought we were looking at younger
kids one of those boomer ass [ __ ]
this guy i'm getting uh
yes some kind of energy am i getting
from here there's something that makes
me feel bad because it's like
i don't let them keep this secret why
don't we go to page 12.
and once you read this section here
i think he's high
yeah he might be high you are high
[Laughter]
hi
my name is emily emily james james nice
to meet you james can i hug you sure
okay fantastic
yes okay how long have you been smoking
cigarettes
uh probably
60 years what's your favorite cartoon
ever i like some zap comic stuff from
the 60s okay do you do impressions i
think this guy's high too to be honest i
do but i do impressions of people that
you don't know i don't do them on
purpose they just pop out sometimes it's
just something that happens once in a
while and i notice it but nobody else
notices it but i know that i'm doing an
impression of this person can you sing a
nursery rhyme no yeah i think you're
high you kind of went on this like
tangent about the impressions that you
do of other people
not high i think he's quite yeah that's
what i was saying
something tells me you do smoke with me
this man decides
yeah that confirmed it so wait are they
did they is this kid not high because
they because these two guys admit to
being high so
thank you
good to know i think they're all high
every [ __ ] one
[Music]
the need to give you a hug as well can i
do that oh yeah okay
okay great
there we go and um
hey i got a good sniffer is that what
she's doing
did you say yeah okay he's one of my
favorite flaming hot cheetos do you like
spicy food yeah i mean i like spicy i'm
half mexican
he might be high actually [ __ ] this
video i hate this video
it's stressing me out
do i remind you of a teacher you've ever
had
the ones that caught me smoking i think
they're all high can i go back oatmeal
raisin for a long time but those are
like super [ __ ] up you're high as hell
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
it's just your life yeah i'm pretty used
to it
it must be hard getting jobs
i don't know sometimes like i don't get
let into bar
see he's not i knew it so wait wait wait
wait so so
who's high in this [ __ ] because i don't
want to watch the video
okay
this was such a bait and switch like
they
how
they made him dress like that he's got
weed socks on
can't judge a book by its cover you know
i knew the first guy was innocent it was
his eyebrow arch i'm telling you
i don't know this guy met this guy looks
like a lot of stoners i knew in college
whatever who cares
[ __ ] you cut
facebook's still down
anyone got or let's take some calls i
guess
let's rapid firearm yeah okay
fbi raided her house um
um
we don't have a name anonymous caller
okay anonymous
hey guys um what happened wasn't a raid
it was
wasn't a raid more of a gentle visit
why did they visit you um
all right so
for the sake of the story everything is
alleged
of course just a little bit we know
about that detail that
trouble yeah exactly trouble can find
you no matter what you do
um so this is like last november um
don't know if you remember that little
election we had i did familiar it was
still up in it still up in the air so it
was like the sixth or something like
tension's never been higher in the
country more divided than ever whatever
here i am i'm selling stuff on d-pop do
you guys know what that is
i'm listening i was checking alfredo's
butt to see if he made a diarrhea oh no
totally understand
okay
you're good i'm listening um are we good
yeah i know you're you're good you're
good you're talking about he's clean his
bottle is clean yeah okay
wait can i interrupt for a second go
ahead we have a little theory
have you called in before
oh my god no hold on hold on hold on
hold on
exactly
zach just came in my ear and asked me
while i was already listening to the old
episode i'm ready i'm ready to feel your
accusation and defend myself okay play
the clip play the clip we're gonna we're
sorry but we're like we have a speaking
of fbi we have an fbi's most wanted
prank caller that we're trying to suss
out here no you've been hurt you've been
hurt before and i understand i don't
think it's her
i don't know i thought it was once
i went to the bathroom i thought it was
her so did you guys you checked it
already a beer you want me to do a
comparison
you can do it i'm i'm i guess i'm a
little off
i we have
an important update to this whole troll
hunt to just get people to relax a
little bit okay
you know everybody out there is so sure
that those two girls were the same
really yes
olivia
has spoken to both of them independently
how can this how can you speak them
independently if it's one person said
both of them message
olivia on instagram seems like an
elaborate ruse olivia are you down here
come come come clarify okay this is
interesting they're not the same person
i've never thought there's the same
person there's no way people are getting
so
up in these conspiracies hold on let's
hear from olivia
i did not answer so i haven't talked to
them but both of them messaged me
separately on instagram
and because instagram's still down i
can't do it but i was
hoping to get them both on a call oh
that now that would be interesting that
would be yeah that would close the case
it would
okay so we're working on it zuckerberg
[ __ ] us again yeah right so did they
maybe crush instagram oh my god maybe
okay hold on so
uh caller anonymous caller
okay let me play
i'm reading the text let me see
do you happen to know of an american
couple that you still live in what kind
of tam stamp is this i'm talking friends
okay go ahead and say something please
anonymous caller me
yeah hello
just talk about go continue on your
story how about a white lady and her
husband
yeah that's what i was going to say
they sound similar to the white lady and
her husband
he's gotten a second home an idea
and there was a group of white ladies
that were all friends oh my god
i came in here i was in the bathroom
like do we have that same color wait it
sounds similar though
oh god
we're so paranoid i forgive us
olivia do you are we do you think this
is a potential troll olivia or was she
exonerated
okay olivia's giving you the green light
olivia's giving the green light okay
that's my girl go ahead
apologies we just we're so paranoid and
we want to catch this girl so bad that's
what i said i get it you've been hurt
you gotta you gotta protect your heart
all right go ahead i'm listening fbi
so
sells a shirt on depop and i pack it up
and i have this like tape in my house
that says usps priority mail
so i'm like bringing it to the post
office so i slap it on there normal
interaction
um i bring it to the post office the
lady looked at me like i had 12 heads
like i had just brandished a weapon
she's like where did you get this you
can't use this
and she's like you need to repack this
yada yada
right yep
okay
so
i repack it i get home and i look at the
label and it says
this product is for use with priority
mail misuse may be a violation of
federal law
whatever so i was like
interesting so i'm like telling my
friends like how weird it was how she
reacted i was like i feel like i got put
on a watch list or something and i'm
like joking about it with my dad
whatever we're like joking fbi's gonna
come whatever
so i'm working from home like a week
later my dad comes to my room he's like
the fbi's here to talk to you
so i didn't i don't believe him because
i'm like a 23 year old girl like not
unassuming whatever um
and apparently what happened was he
answered the door and was like
is this about the tape oh god and
they're like
no so long pretty short it wasn't about
that
they keep they thought i was talking
about like snuff film or something i
don't know but
i get downstairs and there's these two
men in street codes street clothes they
have guns in their holsters they have
their badges like
on display
and they're like do you wanna do you
know why we're here i'm like
no like i'd like to know though and they
say do you want to tell me why you were
threatening a senator online
um
and so like the way i tweet i literally
had like i really had no idea what they
were talking about
um
so i don't know if you guys talked about
the meme on the show of the voicemail
when the girl got took off the schedule
and she called her manager rachel
and she said this is for rachel you wait
just what so
what did you tweet that ended up getting
the uh fbi to your house okay
so
he pulled out a stack of papers with my
tweets on them and he reads it i have to
look this man dead in the eyes as he's
reading
this is for miss mcconnell you big fat
white nasty smelling fat [ __ ] why did
you take me off the [ __ ]
schedule
with your dirty white
racist
body ass [ __ ] wait so you go down there
so you you tweeted that to mitch
mcconnell
no i just tweeted that it's like a [ __ ]
it's like a you don't know that video oh
it's a copy pasta yeah did you did you
tag him in the tweet the fbi came to my
house that's pretty good
that's pretty amazing that they have the
resources yeah then we have something
they had they had pictures that i
tweeted of myself it was literally a
picture of me like with my friends with
like a stupid ass caption
they had like a ton of um
they had like one of my house numbers
they were like are you have you ever
been contacted by
people like outside of the united states
like have you ever thought about buying
a gun oh my goodness
literally have you ever been like that
have you ever tweeted at any other
senator or was it only that one time
i mean
did you tweet other senators or was it
just them
it's him
so just that one tweet
yeah and they had that
and they said i was threatening
mitch mcconnell with violence i have to
say that's that's pretty shocking that
everything happening in this big wide
world
that the fbi is trapped
it makes me wonder if mitch mcconnell
directly there is because if you look up
if you during the time it happened to me
if you look up like
um mitch mcconnell there was like a
florida like uh medical students
who
it they they like literally arrested him
for tweeting something so ridiculous
about mitchell so the only explanation
is that mitch saw your tweet and and
bee-lined it to the fbi
that's pretty amazing well
congratulations i did they just come and
scare you and then leave
yeah it was like a scare tactic
should we should we test the theory and
and tweet yeah i think you should mitch
mcconnell's ass yes
i absolutely think you should test that
theory i'm going to come over and beat
your ass is that what you said
yeah yeah well i don't know the chat is
like a little
a little much so don't read the chat
guys i'm not reading the chat i'm sorry
if they're being rude but the chat is
notorious they're like giving they're
giving info
you know they're they're giving and sell
vibes
yeah i'm sorry
chat
i'm not y'all it i'm not reading it so
but thank you for sharing your story i'm
sorry chad is ruthless no problem all
right
bye guys hi thank you thank you
understand when i both have the time i'm
trying to save people from the chat
because they're
dude i gotta i'm i i don't have the chat
open because it's too distracting when
i'm trying to do the show but
why are people so
like y'all gotta trust me to run the
show right
but also there you see making the
callers feel bad what were they saying
just drop it whatever boring normal [ __ ]
the usual [ __ ]
love butt what the [ __ ] are you doing
dude lovebot is wigging the [ __ ] out
right now i do not know what's happening
it's wrong over there without the event
jesus
maybe not one of you guys could have
caught that what happened i didn't even
see it happening
it dude it's like
evie did that everyone saw that but i
missed
he can't take any more dramatic
this guy's on his last leg man even the
we have a little rubber thing that goes
across the screen
stuff
do that everyone saw that
wait i got is there a way for us to get
yeah
yeah
okay okay here we go here we go hold on
hold on
oh oh oh
okay
that was it that was the thousand
percent yo that was manslaughter we
pull it back put it back put it back
baby watch this just watch your foot it
doesn't look good bro
i was like stable i was uh
i'm just glad he's okay well i'm not
sure if i am that was assault
we have to put you on trial they be yeah
love was like
poor love he was in panic he was shocked
but seriously
i did not do anything
no it is passing out i agree it's love
about having a rough time today the same
people who act
does he does it not stay on the stand it
like just randomly like unparks it we
gotta we gotta like get some tools do it
right now it just did it
it wasn't randomly can we put something
in front of it so we can't make it worse
you think so yeah yeah there's censor
here one more time go into park mode
okay all right ah love but
why did the good always die young what
the
it won't stay in park mode
can we just decapitate the wheels watch
that demon die keep him on the stick
yo why don't we just get like a tablet
and [ __ ]
up there you just put like a
super big screen behind that yeah
exactly that would be even better you
can't roll around would you die for me
for me all right come on
okay okay i can i come to the show if my
crew are trying to murder each other
look it just yeah i'm just going to
chill here for a while
stay the [ __ ] out of my section love my
plane hey
you better not talk to me like that
no i'm just kidding
by the way thank you to all of our
members and thank i never properly thank
the donators thank you guys everyone for
supporting so
it means the world it makes everything
possible thank you guys everyone who
supports the show members we love you
membership goes a long way
thank you thank you
is that dkk uh
yeah that's danish
a b commits high treason against love
even the danish are looking after you
all right we have a call from ryan who's
going to try to make me laugh so
ryan you know the rules you have one
minute is it one minute or 30 seconds
one we usually do one minute ryan you
have one minute are you ready
i'm ready
okay you got a story or something right
now
oh no i do uh
i wrote all these jokes i do uh stand up
so
all right well i'm i'm setting up the
quad to water them down a little bit
okay so you know the rules these guys
have but well i guess we have a minute
so we won't buzz you i guess you guys
can buzz them i guess
you can buzz but i'm just gonna say you
know um
don't take it personally i think
everyone can
not everyone can be a comedian why but
but i think you know i don't know your
level of expertise clearly uh you don't
even have to think about it whatever
just do i'm ready
you get what i'm trying to say no
all right
in my experience the hardest part about
being straight is trying your best not
to do anything gay
i had a close friend once tell me that
the prostate is the male g-spot
i said that's cool um why are you
yelling
we should probably just get our food and
leave
with that being said i definitely don't
look forward to getting my prostate
checked in fact i uh i look backwards
have any of you guys ever taken the am i
gay test on facebook
if not don't bother it's 35 minutes of
gay porn and once you get to the end
there aren't even any questions
i don't know what gender fluid means but
it stains
bill cosby is investing in his own brand
of alarm clocks
is that a minute i don't know
it is now that was one minute i didn't
laugh okay but i will compliment you
that
in terms of people we've had call in
uh who practicing stand up your jokes
were tight
they were formulated well
you had a point and a perspective you
had a unique voice i think that there's
some potential there and although i
didn't laugh i do commend you for having
a pretty solid set there
thank you thank you i appreciate it i
love the show by the way big fan thank
you man i appreciate it
uh dan giggled at one point during the i
think the it was like one of the it was
one of these it was a
but
counts does that count yes
was it the bill cosby clockwise
oh you know what i like the one where
you said there's a gay
test on facebook and it's just a bunch
of porn and no questions right that was
the one i was like kind of funny i was
like what is the bill cosby clock uh
joke um
what's the i guess yeah that one's a
little watered down okay you want to
give me the full thing
you mean watered down like you're trying
to condense it or it's too graphic the
whole thing
uh it's it's probably a little too
graphic
for youtube live
well thank you for considering that
i appreciate you considering
considering all right ryan well good
luck out there okay i think you i think
i think keep going man you think you got
a skill out there all right
appreciate that thank you all right keep
going all right
bye
not bad
brian
you know
you know
my mom is dating a 21 year old
50 year old mom dating a 21 year old
loves love is interested
are you into milf genre love
no i don't know
sadly not are you willing to come out
today and tell us what your genre is
no well no i just wanted to ask i mean
some people are open about it some
aren't
he's into the fico
yes
i wonder if there is fica porn
i mean that's not us maybe that's
something
new
what does that even mean i mean that's
just they're having tea
they're having a short little uh
pastry break and then one thing leads to
another and but they have to be fast
maybe that's the fika thing it has to be
like fast
yeah maybe i don't know
it's uninvented so
the thing is do you look something up
baby it's pretty invented
you found something fun a lot
so what someone
does that explain what you're seeing
maybe i haven't opened it but i'm seeing
a lot of results
yeah it means something very different
in italian
now that's a different kind of fika
yeah an interesting could still be
considered a fika in the right
circumstances
make ethan laughs attempt with a
keemstar joke you know how to win me
over lauren
go ahead you lauren you with me
did i accept it or no i'm confused
no i didn't okay
lauren
lauren hey how are you you got something
for me
hey
what up big pam i see you're from texas
yeah
yeah i'm sorry i'm locked down here i'm
sorry about all my texas jokes
no no no no i'm a nurse and okay it is
real and i actually moved from the er to
working inside the house because it's
[ __ ] crazy over here how what's it
like working in the as a nurse during
covet in texas of all places
well
things considered i was actually uh
pregnant at the start of the pandemic
and so
february all the way to march i i
realized i was pregnant and i just
decided to get out to texas is [ __ ]
crazy about it and they don't believe
anything and um i just did a lot of
evidence-based research and decided to
pull myself out of the er and focus on
taking care of my baby and he's turning
one year old next year i mean next week
congratulations
you've just been dodging
hot textiles you don't believe in the
vaccine don't believe in the mask so i'm
just been stuck at home i work i work
from home now well i'm glad that you're
out in a safe situation so that's good
that's good
so lauren you've got a keemstar joke for
me
yeah oh my god i have several actually
and like i said i'm a nurse i'm not a
stand-up comic and so i'm trying to show
up all these due to trying to be
stand-up comics and make you laugh here
should we throw that should we should we
throw the timer on
was it just one joke because it's not
really necessary but i mean okay
okay lauren let's let's see
let's let's let's see what you got she's
a nurse let's see if the nurse can show
up these stand-up comedians well let's
see yeah you've got yeah the topic is
good
all right well i've got the clock ready
so are you are you good to go
i think so i love you dan you're awesome
oh stay in the wizard oh well thank you
[Applause]
all right ready i'm ready all right 60
seconds on the clock here we go and
begin
well let's let's start off by saying
stand up comedians need to know who
their audience is so let's first start
off with the dan the wizard he is on the
moral support of the the whole crew so i
the moral compass on that dude is
amazing so that's what this show is
standing on zach the sound lad man just
throwing it down with all the buttons
and pushing all the right notes and you
know not just the
the sound by buttons but you know the
girl buttons too you know anyway so i
just want to start off by saying um why
does keemstar
never get speeding tickets y'all
what because he actually slows down at
school zones and you know what is
keemstar's favorite type of garden guys
anybody know what is that what's that
kindergarten y'all come on now
get me back
can't see zach
all right that's one minute and i you
seem to you seem to make me well keep
going i mean yeah i guess we don't need
to stop that's amazing it's getting
heated up y'all let's keep it going
let's keep it going
uh
what's the difference between
a triller fight show
and
mom's basement what's that what's that
no [ __ ] difference y'all let's be
real nobody watches that [ __ ]
that's good okay i like that joke
[Applause]
very good but um i already i went over
to the time y'all i'm sorry
i think you i think you won i think a
resounding w that was a dummy
lauren the nurse yeah laura the nurse
what great energy
lauren has you really got zach yeah yeah
obviously the
we're gonna have to say goodbye
thank you for calling congratulations we
all laughed but we have some deep dish
pizza here with my name
all over it oh you guys you enjoy you
enjoy thank you so much and i love you
guys thank you thank you thank you
thank you
troopers forever bring that [ __ ]
let's go all right let's take a look at
this so are these all the same just
classic oh my god
this thing is heavy
holy [ __ ] this is the heaviest square
pound for pound
the heaviest pie
holy 15 pounds between the two
and they're not even that big of pizza
it's like a 10 inch pizza
all right so wait what are the
difference here sam
i said one is just cheese and one is
veggie what did i get i don't
i guess that one's the veggie so that's
just like a cheese pie this thing isn't
even cut sam i well i think you need to
kind of um it's not even cut
what oh it's literally not covered it's
not cut well we gotta cut it that's
pretty like john teach you how to eat
uncut pizzas but this is like a
conversational experience yo i've never
had a pie
how would how did is this a goof that
they didn't cut the pie maybe
that's probably are you serious
yo
have you weighed that's heavy right
oh my goodness she said the two together
was 15 pounds
all right is pete can pizza be pie
we're about to find out ladies and
gentlemen
this is a big moment
you're serving it up right now this is a
100 donation i just saw thank you thank
you thank you guys that's
emotion emotion
oh emotion
interesting it's uh donating
99.99 hey my 25th birthday is coming up
on the 7th and i want to know everyone's
weirdest or most what the [ __ ] birthday
moment also i'm a huge h3 fan and teddy
fresh fan thank you for everything you
guys do
uh you get me through my hard times
peace and love peace and love thank you
jackie so much that's actually a good
question i have a funny one i have i
have a kind of a what the [ __ ] one for
sure so
this was
yeah so we went to my favorite my dad
took us all
this was a weird one because it was
his birthday
and for his birthday we all went out to
our favorite mexican restaurant in
ventura where i grew up
and my dad told them that it was my
birthday for some reason
i guess as a goof jokester
oh my
god
you all have had this [ __ ] before
yeah
oh my god
now chicago and like
i'm sure somebody will say oh that's not
the real stuff or whatever
[Music]
can we go to the chew zone real quick
enter the chew zone
is this the veggie one
that's the red there's a lot of veggie
on it
there we are
um
[Music]
this is that this has got to be the veg
you gave me
[Music]
thank you mmm
look mushrooms on it though
i'm not hungry at all it's fine
[Music]
the pizza's the crust is a little weird
[Applause]
[Music]
well
thoughts
i love it not just if you like it but is
this are you eating a pie right now
um
[Music]
yeah
yeah
yeah i mean we did it
we convinced him
is it a pie
i mean
it just happened maybe it's like crying
i don't know i have my headphones on it
can't really hear it's very pie-y so
i see it so here's the question
can you see yourself smelling this from
the adjacent room
and the little smell lines come and
wiggle up to your nose and you start
floating through the air and kind of
like snake through the air
if i if i smelled pizza i would
definitely
come floating in
[Music]
oh look love's got a great example look
at that
what is this weird ass [ __ ]
it's like family guy it was episode of
family guy where they go to different
universes and this is when they went to
the disney universe
where in the episode they didn't like um
jewish people
say well yeah in that episode
well
i'm just gonna calculate those out there
because that's a joke on disney because
walt disney was
rumored to be a virulent anti-semite
but they acknowledged it in episode two
yeah wow that was fun that was good
wouldn't mind another one
i'll wait till the show's over though
okay
people don't need that
yeah so my dad we went to my dad's
favorite mexican restaurant and he said
it's my birthday
so i had no idea
what was going to happen
but around dinner
everyone comes out with the cake
and the candles and
everything but then they come to me
and i'm just confused like oh what what
happened they got it wrong
but then what really surprises me is
that when they're done singing
the waiter smashes my head into the cake
as hard as you can
and i don't expect i inhale the cake and
i puke
and i'm crying i was pretty young so i
was i was bawling my eyes out and i was
puking and it was like super traumatic
and uh what the [ __ ] i was just kind of
shocked by the whole thing i just didn't
understand why it was happening to me
so that's my crazy birthday story anyone
else got one
how old were you
i was really [ __ ] up under 10 for sure
holy [ __ ]
yeah they slammed my [ __ ] dome into
the cake dude
that's [ __ ]
nice remember my mom i strained me to
the bathroom as i was crying
you always got to bring the cake to the
face not the face to the cake because
there's so many bad videos when you slam
the head into like the tables
interesting observation
yeah he's gotta bring the kids bring the
cake
to the face
a life lesson to live by great point
anyone else
um
i almost
died in a high speed police chase on my
birthday once
okay
i was uh
i think it was i was turning 22 i want
to say
and i had just purchased a car from a
family member in the bay area and it was
my first car
that was a stick shift and so i was
supposed to drive down i was supposed to
learn on it for a few days up there and
then drive it back to la
but
after a day of doing i was pretty
comfortable and it was my birthday that
night
and a lot of uh my friends
had wanted me to come celebrate with
them i was like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna
do it so i left at like
7 00 p.m to drive down to l.a
like three hours into the drive i'm
going through like salinas or like one
of those towns like kind of rural towns
in central california
and
on my left i see a bunch of flashing
lights and headlights and it takes me a
second to register that i'm in the far
left lane oh my god i'm like what's
going on and i look over my shoulder and
there is a high-speed police chase on
the wrong side of the freeway coming up
on me from the wrong side of the freeway
and the guy that they're chasing just as
he passes me cuts across the median hits
the dirt and the divider and goes
sailing through the air not kidding like
airborne vehicle about 10 feet in front
of my car that i had just got that day
or that morning
um and then slams into the barrier on
the other side and like spins out and
all of a sudden and i like slammed on
brakes obviously there was like one
other it was the middle of the night it
was like midnight
so it was almost completely empty road
so i'd slam on the brakes and like kind
of dodge out of the way and then he gets
surrounded by like 15 cop cars
um and i just kept going along my way
and about you know 30 seconds later the
adrenaline hit me and i had to pull over
because i was like shaking from just
like the cops never checked on you or
anything no
were you by chance listening to credence
clean water or anything uh and leading
up to no i would have been listening
what's the uh
credence cline
the uh dukes of hazard uh
theme song he's running down yeah that's
running up and trucking yeah wow
probably the craziest thing i've ever
seen on the road that is crazy yeah and
it was uh it had just passed past
midnight and it so it was my birthday um
when this happened yeah sounds like
something you have a good birthday
beside that
yeah i got back three or four hours
later to la and uh all my friends uh
were at my house uh waiting for me for a
surprise party at like three in the
morning nice that was pretty cool well i
called them and told them what had just
happened and they were all like
that's nice kind of thing weren't you
pissed tired
i was very tired yes
but there are cures for that oh yeah
they're
really like what
what kind of cares damn
you could eat orange yeah
caffeine
caffeine's a legal cure for weariness
any other birthday submissions
not really nap that's it that's all we
got i well i was i was celebrating a
birthday not my birthday over the
weekend
and i saw a pursuit um we were in the
parking lot and the cops corner this car
one in the front one in the back and
they come out guns drawn and this is 15
feet away from us
and they're like get out of the car put
your hands blah blah blah the dude
[ __ ] bolts
15 feet in front of us with the cops
chasing him and this guy was running as
fast as he [ __ ] could it was insane
so we're like what the [ __ ] happened we
look into it
he was he was armed
he ran into a convenience store
punched a woman multiple times
went into hiding and then they finally
arrested him and found him but it was
[ __ ] crazy did you happen to listen
did you hear any click clearance clean
water coming in from his car or on his
person uh i've
not
they know okay didn't get there but i
i've never seen anything like that in
person before wow yeah it was something
from cops so you know
i had to get together on my birthday
once and then like it ended early
and this girl was going to come over but
then on the way there she said we're
just friends don't try anything and then
we ended up playing donkey kong you guys
know the rest but
that's my only birthday story we already
killed it
oh that was on your birthday mm-hmm
interesting that's a new uh yeah i
didn't know that's a whole new uh
dynamic there i didn't know but i
haven't saw him i celebrated my birthday
since
i'm gonna start calling it your bongo
day dude yeah
yeah so there's one more caller i want
to take destiny
uh from san diego
destiny what would you like to discuss
today
this is your destiny's calling
you're dead you're missing your destiny
here
are you sure i don't think you
i don't think you took it i don't see
them in the room well i see it
host room destiny
maybe mine is there 20 seconds oh you're
right okay but i commute and then i can
unmute
maybe she's um
she's been on hold for almost two hours
so they might have given up maybe she's
sleeping
wake up
wake up
destiny
oh my god
all right people at teddy fresh are like
what the [ __ ] are they doing today
it's my destiny
all right thank you destiny
it's great talking to you yeah great
call
we're almost at three hours all right
guys it's been a h3 tv
classic and i've got some more pie to
eat
me too
[ __ ] pecan [ __ ] apple
i mean can we make pizza like any other
category food because that'll be my
favorite
pizza
burger
pizza sandwich
just make it all the day of wrecking
will come
all right guys we'll see you on um
thursday wednesday for members should do
another reminder about the schedule
because there's a lot more people
watching now than at the beginning
reminder schedule we'll also say it on
thursday
but just a quick reminder on the
scheduling
um
after dark on friday starting at 11 this
week
and then on monday a week from today
h3tv is going to be on tuesday
instead of monday me and either are
celebrating our anniversary so we will
be
taking an extended weekend
and i thank you all so much
so we'll see you guys on thursday
members on wednesday
friday after dark
and uh sunday leftover saturday for
members god bless you all
stay safe be good
[Music]
you